Are you recording?
We're broadcasting.
Hey,
every buddy I forgot to say.
Um,
let's get going.
Buckle up bitches or anythings like that.
Um,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight.
Enter into code name.
Rogan.
You get 15% off the number ones.
I still miles Giovanni's in the house.
Like fuck yeah,
bitches.
Some music
cause it wouldn't be a podcast.
See
now,
boom,
we're in action.
See that Mazda Vania it feels,
it feels a lot more legit right now.
It does.
My good pal Mazda Bronys with us and we
have to talk shit before we get started
about the fucking Tascam Dr 100.
This is our third one.
You dirty bitches.
How about k?
Tascam MP,
three recorder people get
your fucking shit together.
But ass cam,
that's how bad they are.
Yes,
look,
there you go.
There you go.
Not tascam ask him.
Says Mazda Brian.
It gets all these great reviews and
honestly it makes some great sound.
It sounds awesome.
It's a,
it's an excellent piece of kit as it were.
But unfortunately it
fucking breaks all the time.
This is our third one and no I don't
send it in for warranty cause I ain't got
that kind of time and I'm
a fancy man Mazda binding.
So just order another one with that one.
Click Shit on amazon.com
this is the third one.
You're like Lex Luther and superman and
never wear the same pair of socks two
days in a row.
I'm like a black rapper throws
away his white sneakers.
Yeah man.
What the fuck?
We used to go on the road with Charlie
Murphy and Charlie Murphy used the
throwing new sneakers and
we'd get like a little scuff,
like that's it.
Silver,
silver.
It's over.
It's over for those sneakers.
You're a comedian,
you're not playing basketball.
Charlie Murphy,
he wears like those
ridiculous rapper chains.
You know they're covered in diamonds
and bling bling and he doesn't wear them
all.
When he goes on stage,
he takes them off and he
puts him on his cousin.
Richard said,
Richard is like his tour manager
and he'll ritual hold on the chains.
Is that in case he gets shot or something,
he just doesn't want to
blink too hard was on stage.
It doesn't want to
distract from the message.
It's really hard for a
comedian have to be to blinky.
Like only black comedians can be blinking.
There's no like,
yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
You can't Williams can pull it off.
It's got that whole pip
persona thing going on.
But yeah,
white guy with a lot of diamonds
like went to fucking saw.
I saw prince in concert recently.
I saw Princeton concert.
It was amazing.
The guy's amazing.
He's amazing.
I was like a comedian could
never dress like prince.
And do you get a certain league at a
certain license to be weird with music?
Yeah,
exactly.
Like he came out at at one point with
like a like for like for leg warmer thing.
Can you imagine as a comedian come in
next to the stage Joe Rogan's show up in
her leg.
Warmers are great.
He just pushes it man and
chicks fucking love him.
Oh my God.
There's,
there's something about
him that to them is very,
it's,
it's weird.
He's like five foot three,
he's 18 and he just was women's clothes.
But he's sexy though.
They want to fuck him.
He owns it.
That's what it is.
I was telling I was there with my wife.
I was like,
there's nothing else this guy could do.
Like he's made to do this.
Like he could never be that.
He wouldn't like it.
Mostly with like a ups guy.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if he shows up,
he says you can't.
And he owns it.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
He's a brilliant artist and he,
he's amazing.
He's just a weird guy and I think,
you know,
all brilliant.
They're really brilliant.
Artists are off I'm finding are
almost completely fucking crazy.
Oh absolutely.
Yeah.
All the good ones from back.
I mean even like all the composers,
Beethoven,
all those guys were all nuts.
Their fucking minds.
Yeah.
I have to beat him.
Think about there was fucking nothing
but acts is hitting trees back then.
That was the sound.
They heard one lump and one
guy figures out and you know,
not really,
but you know,
people back then,
you know,
that did figure out how to orchestrate
music and how to create music and compose
incredible works of music that are still
listened to hundreds of years later.
Oh yeah.
You know,
that's pretty nuts man.
And we don't even know what
his shit really sounded like.
That's the craziest,
but also the crate,
I was listening to the radio one time,
they're talking about,
because some of these guys
like autistic autistic people,
some of them were like
geniuses in one way and,
and you know,
autistic or they have
problems in another way.
This one kid,
they were saying,
um,
autistic couldn't communicate that
he's at home with his mom and dad.
They live,
they watch a,
uh,
some,
some movie that had like a Beethoven
Concerto in it to just watch it,
you know,
once the,
because like 12 years old,
the mother goes to sleep
middle of the night,
wakes up and thinks that
the TVs playing it again,
the kids at the piano playing that song
from watching it once he's just learned
the song.
So,
so these guys are geniuses in
one way and crazy in another way.
Yeah.
We talked about autistic,
autistic savant on the podcast
a bunch of times before,
cause there's so many really amazing
examples of that kind of power.
I bet a lot of famous musicians and
composers and geniuses in the past were
probably autistic savant.
I just didn't know how to diagnose it.
They just considered them geniuses.
Yeah.
Or maybe there's like,
I mean there's even certain,
like as you were talking about,
you know,
prince,
like there's certain levels of it,
like,
you know,
like you got the,
the rock star who's brilliant and amazing,
but like,
he can't like,
you know,
remember his address.
You know what I'm saying?
It needs to someone,
a baby's born.
Yeah.
And he's the one to babysit them.
You know,
I think that's,
I think a lot of that stuff is that
sure.
You know?
Yeah.
You wouldn't want,
isn't it amazing that music for like
hundreds and hundreds of years was just
written down like you couldn't record it.
So like,
like composers,
like when they created a piece of work,
it's actually like writing and
that's how like this is my work,
this is what I've done.
I've combined all these
notes in a certain way.
But you didn't even get
to listen to them do it.
Right.
You know,
they never got a chance
to record anything.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll never hear Beethoven
actually directing any music,
you know,
or anytime travel.
Yeah.
Until the time travel.
But isn't that amazing now
that for hundreds of years
it was just written down,
you know,
fuck it.
I wonder if it would sound
any different to like,
I wa like it'd be listening.
The Beatles when they
released the Mano version,
which was supposedly to
superior version was the Mano,
uh,
versions of all the Beatles songs cause
they were recorded in mono and then
later they remastered them at
stereo hysteria was so popular.
And that's what you grew up on,
was listening to stereo music of versions
of what was not supposed to be stereo.
So people actually like
listening to the Mano versions.
Now I wonder how much of that
is like people just being like,
Oh,
you should've heard that.
you know what I'm saying?
People do that.
Although you should all man,
the classic that it,
uh,
when in reality,
I mean it's like,
you know,
HD versus [inaudible] kind of
mixed different too though,
like things that come out in stereo that
weren't really necessarily supposed to
be out more.
You know,
it's so I actually have
both versions and uh,
it definitely,
I could see what people are saying.
It's more hardcore hitting and everything
seems mixed properly compared to like
what now?
Like some guy in some THX labs like,
no,
I think this little jingle
over here should be louder.
You know,
I think I'm going to have
to get into fucking vinyl.
I think I'm going to have to buy a record
player and some headphones and listen
to what the fuck everybody's saying.
Because when you talk to
like real audio files,
they'll tell you that like a vinyl LP is
a way to go and then you lose something
in the sound.
When you go to CD you lose
like our quality a layer.
Can you even buy a record planning now?
These actually so records at best buy now.
Oh really?
Yeah.
The music industry is trying to find a
new thing and which one of the things
that's going retro going back to
vinyl because it sounds better,
whatever.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's all up to debate on my opinion.
How funny is that?
Like you think like old
TVs will make a comeback.
Wouldn't that be funny if you go in,
you're like,
this is not HD.
Yeah.
Well it seems like
get away with it with blueray where they
don't have to have compression anymore.
You know,
they have compression to
get it to CD to digitize it.
Like maybe they could add that quality
to it if they stretched it out and made
it a larger file.
I think they do.
Yeah.
I think flack or whatever that
version is,
I think that that is something that's
very close to it or what people can see.
It just depends how big
of a real audio people.
So the reason why I even brought it up,
but somebody on my message board made a
post suggesting that I put out my next
CD on vinyl and I'm like,
wow,
I've never even thought about doing that.
That's like,
it's kind of weird suggestion.
I might be kind of cool.
It is a cool idea.
It's kind of like,
I don't know if you heard about this,
but I guess Steven Wright is
writing a novel on Twitter.
Do you hear about it?
Did
you hear about this?
No,
he straight up like
he,
you know,
he found out he took,
you know how he's like,
I mean he's known for the shorter jokes,
right?
So they decided,
well,
Twitter is about being short,
so I'm going to write a novel.
So supposedly he's writing a novel.
And you can come in at any point and
you might not know what's going on.
He doesn't care.
He's just good album.
I have to follow him.
Is it Stephen or Steve with a v I think
is with The v actually I think steering
right but,
but,
but based on,
but what I'm saying it's
like the same thing if you,
if you bust it out with like everyone
else is coming out with like the new hot,
I'm going to put my,
put my album out like this,
like that.
And you bust out with,
you know,
a record vinyl.
That might be a way to go.
This can't be him.
He only has 15,000 followers.
I Dunno.
I'm not sure.
Is that a real,
yeah,
that could probably
is about right.
How do you,
how could you find out if
it's the real deal or not?
Well usually they're verified.
I'm verified Joan Rivers right here
says it's verified follow Joan Rivers.
But Steven Wright doesn't say verified.
I'm going to take a chance
and following me anyway.
Cause I think a lot of those old school
guys like Steven Wright or probably just
now embracing technology,
so that might be a real number.
He might really only have seven.
We could rerelease her
website and bitmaps.
What does bitmaps instead
of jpegs we can go.
Really?
Yeah,
that'd be good.
Vinyl,
a photo cause discussion,
every crappy,
everything.
We all go back to like three second
video gifts instead of having Ustream,
we just have a Gif animation writing.
He is writing a novel writing a novel.
Right?
Oh this is hilarious.
He's hilarious.
He's writing a fucking novel on Twitter.
That's funny.
I can't wait to follow.
I heard that.
I was like,
that's crazy.
That is such a great idea.
And he ends TBC on like every post to
be continued to be getting delirious.
He continued and you get to
just follow along with it.
This is so strange.
Isn't that crazy?
But addressing your question,
this was extremely tiring
for Harold because of his
attention with drift and for
some reason the abstract speech
that his mother was making,
like a toy train.
His brain would stay firmly on track,
weaving,
turning through it to be continued
previously unconnected subjects.
Harold had the opposite of add.
He needed to go go some
to some school somewhere.
Some typo needed to go,
some to some school somewhere and
learned how to space to be continued out
to be continued and then out
space to be continued out.
The last dream he had was about a man
who invented mirrors when howled workup
the next day,
all he could remember was
that he to be continued,
had a dream about us.
Like this is ridiculous.
This is definitely him.
This is definitely happen.
But this is one of the weirdest things
I've ever heard anybody doing that.
Steve writes a maniac.
You know,
he was the guy who was single handedly
his success through this monkey wrench
into the whole,
uh,
Boston comedy scene.
There's a,
there's a great documentary by this guy,
Fran Salameda.
Fuck.
I'd have to look it up
with the name of it is.
Have you ever worked with them before?
Yeah.
Fran was a comic from Boston,
Boston Combo.
How did he throw a wrench into the scene?
Because he got successful.
And um,
when he got successful,
everybody kind of
freaked out and was like,
what Stan went,
standups stood out.
That's what it's called.
Bob Boston was this incredible
place where there was so many great,
great comedians that were local guys
and they would just work locally,
constantly.
And all of a sudden Steven Wright got
discovered and Steven Wright started doing
Letterman and Carson
and everybody was like,
Holy Shit.
Then he got his HBO special
and then everybody was like,
where's mine?
When is this going to happen for me?
And it kind of like changed the tone
of the town because it used to be this
almost like,
I want to say artists' colony,
but not so fucking gay.
They were savages.
They were crazy.
Coke's Norton,
we'd Smolkin whiskey drink and animals
and they were fucking hilarious.
And they were just doing
it to make everybody laugh
and to get by and get paid.
But then all of a sudden,
you know,
the,
the dream sort of appeared
in Steven Wright form.
Steven,
right?
All of a sudden became fucking
huge at famous and rational.
And these guys were like,
yeah,
Steven's good,
but I'm fucking good too.
You know?
And it kind of changed the
whole tone of the town.
You know,
guys started like really
working towards deals,
you know,
I mean it's not necessarily a bad thing,
but it became,
you know,
that it became,
there was a different goal on the horizon.
It wasn't just being funny.
It was crazy how success
can get in the way of art.
Yes.
And often does often
does but doesn't have to,
you know,
manageable.
It's a manageable,
like people say,
oh you sold out.
I'm like shut up stupid.
You don't even know what
you're talking about.
As long as you're still doing good stuff.
Part of it is like,
I mean like with you,
I mean I know like,
you know,
seeing you at the comedy
store when I first was,
you know,
when I first was starting,
they're like,
the good thing about you is even when
you had a show or anything going,
you still kept that mentality of I've got
to get up and create and write and you
continue to do that.
And so the idea is you can get out of
that quote unquote artists' colony,
you know,
with success.
But then you within,
you remind yourself,
it's like a boxer.
I got to keep training.
You know?
It's also,
I think your motivation changes.
Your motivation goes from the bean.
The motivation of a odd,
just trying to make it,
I want success,
I want to be,
you know,
recognized too.
You get some success,
then you go,
okay,
now I just want to do good stuff.
I just want to have fun.
Now my interest is just on the jokes.
It's just in creating the new bit,
just not putting the act together and
it actually becomes more fun that way.
Is it?
When you do like and you get,
so when you call it with a bit
or something that you'd let him,
it's like it's as good as getting
a big paycheck where you're like,
oh,
that was cool.
I mean it's even,
they were saying like,
I mean it's just,
you're so excited about it,
you know?
And it's because it doesn't always co
one of the problems of success as it
becomes harder to write in newer stuff
unless if you put yourself in those lab
kind of situations where you're saying,
okay,
I'm going to work out some new stuff.
You know when people come expecting
you to always gonna you know,
do those killer whatever things,
you know.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a problem.
But you know,
that's fun.
It's a fun problem.
It's,
it's a tester but it's fantastic.
It's one of the reasons why we like doing
that sounds comedy hall to this real
small,
it's like 80 people and I just,
I'll fuck around and not even know what
I'm really going to say about something
and they know that
that's what you're doing.
They know that you're fucking around a
lot and I do most of my real bits too.
I want to give them solid stand up,
but I also want to use the opportunity
to fuck around and stretch out.
I never do a full,
like a full sacrifice set.
I won't like go up there with
only new bits and just eat dick.
I don't like doing that man.
I don't think they like it either.
The only time,
uh,
I've recently tried
something like that is a,
the laugh factory was doing some
with Kevin Nealon on Tuesdays.
We were,
was known as seven minutes in new material
and then Kevin Nealon comes on stage
and sits with you and Kinda,
he's a funny guy.
He kind of risks with you and kind of
like makes fun of the material but also
gives you some ideas and uh,
and the audience,
well they're supposed to know that
that's what they're there for.
Half the audit,
whenever I go up there and go,
how many you guys knew
you were coming for this?
And like two or three people clap.
The rest of the thought was a real show.
But the idea is you're supposed to go
up with seven minutes of brand new,
like never try.
So what I,
every time I've gone up there,
I've liked just gone into my blackberry
and looked at the ideas I've had that
I've just put down that
I haven't riffed on.
I just go up and riff
and it's so much now.
He never had and beautiful and
real and good things come out of,
yeah.
You know gotta take chances,
man.
That's a standup comedy is one.
That's one of the most
important things about it.
Constantly moving,
constantly taking chances.
Some new thing comes out in the news.
Get onstage that day
when with Anthony Wiener,
when when the ship went down,
I went on stage that night and had 10 new
minutes cause I was just writing about
it all day.
How ridiculous it was.
I was just laughing and we're living in
a fucking Coen brothers movie manner.
No,
I'm good.
It's even now steady number.
Fucking guys name his wiener and he's
taking pictures of his Dick and sending
get to women.
I mean it's,
it doesn't even seem
like it could be real.
I know.
It's ridiculous.
It was a movie you would go,
that's shitty writing.
This is through right?
Yeah.
Come on dude.
You gotta go another name here.
It's like whenever these senators
get caught doing gay shit,
it's always the same thing I
think is anti gay senators.
They get called gay and out.
You're like,
goddammit man,
it's it is it that easy?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
And this is the solution.
This is really what's going on.
Well there's so much of that going on now.
It seems like I just,
they just had a,
I just saw Andrew is Andrew Cuomo,
Mario Cuomo son.
He's now the governor of New York is,
I think it's Andrew or I think anyway,
governor Cuomo was up
there talking about some,
he was,
they just showed a clip
of him and I was like,
Oh man,
cause he seems like he's,
he's like,
he's a Cuomo.
He kind of has like,
seems like he's legit
right in back of my mind.
I'm like,
I hope he's not banging some lady.
I was like,
it's going to come.
cause it almost,
if it's a lady he could live
through with light duty,
but you know,
now you can't even live.
I mean it's like,
you know the wiener,
we don't know.
I mean did he,
do he actually have sex with him?
It was just like sending
pictures of his penis a freak.
He's just a freak.
Yeah.
So now he's got,
so what I'm saying is like,
you can't,
like if,
if government give governor Cuomo Cuomo
Cuomo were found to be having an affair,
he's done.
I mean,
can't,
yes,
I agree with you.
Yeah.
And you know,
in this day and age,
this is really going to be a time real
soon where there's no one left to run for
office.
It's funny,
everybody's got fucking Skelton's.
That's hilarious.
Do you think that wiener during the whole,
that whole week before he stepped down,
do you think he was like,
please let there be a
death deadly hurricane.
Please let there be an
earthquake in Africa.
What the fuck?
Right.
Gary condit thing.
Remember when nine 11 happened?
You remember Gary Condit and Chandra Levy?
Chandra Levy was his assistant.
She turned out missing.
Everybody thought he killed her because
he was having an affair with her.
There was all this craziness.
And then,
you know,
they found her body,
and,
but he got off,
he got off on it.
Yeah.
My God.
And they apparently connected
her murder to a bar.
A guy had killed the
few women in that area,
so it might've actually been legit.
Serial killer.
Okay,
well who the fuck
it's that concept that you
had this kind of fight.
You should riff on that about pretty
soon there'd be no one left to run and
it'll,
it'll be like the most unsexy,
evil people.
Like,
so someone,
no one wants to have any sex with.
Like you gotta get like
really ugly kind of like,
you know,
just like wardee people like you,
you gotta you gotta be someone that's not,
no one's attracted to the
run cause they're like,
well there's no way no
anyone had sex with that guy.
I think it's going to come down
to a point real soon where we've,
we have to come to grips with the
fact that everybody that wants to be
president,
anybody that wants to
be in control like that,
there's some serious like sexual
weirdness going on with you.
That's some domination shit.
You want to run things.
Yeah.
But also with power,
I mean that's like,
I mean that's part of like the,
you know,
that's part of what comes with it.
I mean,
it was funny too,
was the one that uh,
Dominique stress con when they,
when the IMF guy,
yes.
Yeah.
What was funny was they were,
I don't know,
explain the story.
Does that make strides in the trashcan
was the president of the IMF and a,
he staying at the Sofitel hotel
and a $3,000 a night suite,
he's also supposedly going to be the next
possible possible president of France.
So he's being geared up for that.
And so the maid comes in to clean the
place and he shows up naked and he
basically think he chased her around
and tried to rape her or something.
Fuck their mouth.
Did he?
Oh my God.
So he,
so he,
whatever he meant.
So the story,
who knows what really happened,
but,
but the,
but the thing it was funny is,
so he's a French dude and then,
and of course,
you know,
then he tried and then he tried to leave
the country should say allegedly fucked
her mouth,
allegedly.
Is it out?
I'll say allegedly.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's what our sources,
that's what are sources have told us.
The Internet.
Yeah.
I didn't look into that at all,
but,
um,
uh,
but the point,
but what's funny is,
is I was reading this,
some of the French,
the French reaction were there,
they were like,
they were saying like,
well,
the French aren't that
phased by the whole,
they're like,
they expect their politician to be,
oh,
if you're a politician and
France isn't bang in somebody,
then it's weird.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
You know?
Well,
you know,
uh,
there's a,
there's a thing that we've talked about
on this podcast before called toxo
plasma and it's a,
a,
a cat parasite that infects a human
beings and changes their behavior.
And it makes men reckless.
It makes men very aggressive and
reckless makes them do crazy shit.
And,
uh,
there's a huge population of a,
a high rate of infection
rather in France and Francis,
like 80%,
80% of the people are infected by this
toxoplasma as much as 80% in some areas.
GS,
which is insane.
And it,
it's uh,
it's a parasite and it's just to
management as you men and women,
sex women.
But the women,
it's tougher to document how it affects
women because they think it makes them
more submissive.
But with,
with men,
it makes them aggressive jerks
and makes them really reckless.
That explains a lot.
Yeah.
You went to smoke something and catch it.
So that's why like pregnant women
aren't supposed to touch cat shit.
If they are telling that to
your wife when she was pregnant,
don't touch any kitty litter.
Don't ever go near any cats.
Oh Wow.
It's why because of a this toxoplasma
but huge percentage of people.
I mean if this guy has
toxo if he's from France,
I mean he might make them loked out
where he just whips his dick out on the
main.
That'd be great.
That'd be a great,
uh,
a plea and the court be like,
I have toxoplasma plasma know,
feel free to use it.
I'll be honored if you guys use that.
Uh,
that maybe I possibly had
some [inaudible] saying.
So plasma defense,
it's um,
it's very possible.
I would like to see this guy tested.
I mean,
if he really did so do something
fucking reckless and crazy.
But I think anybody who wants to be
in a position of power like that,
a lot of them have sexual things.
You know,
Clinton would just whip his
dick out on girls crazy is that,
it's just where he was the president.
He would just whip his dick on it.
State troopers and
fucking good typists and
great Terry.
You know what I was thinking?
I was thinking like all these guys,
like when you get to that level of power,
you should have like,
uh,
like I was thinking you should have like
a counselor that's walking around with
you 24,
seven and you're like,
Hey,
I think I'm about to whip out my dick.
And like,
that's not a good idea.
Well,
what's funny is I realized
if you ever were a dude,
the dude evasive,
I'd be like,
yeah,
what about your Dick?
Let's just like go to mind.
You said totally do that.
That'd be awesome.
You want to bang the made you
should totally being the mayor,
the president IMF washed.
Yeah.
How about Arnold man?
Oh my God.
How about that?
Crazy ass all.
Just fucking everyone who's in his house.
How funny is that?
If you're in his house,
he fucks you.
That's just the rule.
Yeah,
no,
he was fucking her for 10 years,
man.
Crazy.
And she was not attract.
Oh,
it didn't matter.
What do you like?
I'm a hard on it.
She was like cleaning is like,
I must do,
you know is like he just
bent over and I mean it's,
it's ridiculous.
I was,
I jokingly said like maybe he's
trying to save money on childcare.
Like,
you know,
have a baby with a nanny.
She's got to take care of his free,
you know,
Arnold is probably like
when he started banging her,
I mean he was so big,
you know,
when he was bodybuilding
in and be like that.
And there's only one way to do that
and you have to be on steroids,
you have to be on testosterone.
And Arnold was like,
you know,
known allegedly for being a guy who would
take just fucking massive quantities
of everything.
That's why he was so huge.
You look at the photos of him back when
he was Mister Olympia and holy fucking
shit.
Well you know the levels of testosterone,
that guy must have been taken
where probably through the roof.
So he probably just would fuck everything.
Oh yeah,
Naomi,
I fuck you.
This is everything.
Doesn't that,
doesn't that lower your sex drive or are
supposed to like make your penis while
what happened?
Cause we lowers your body's natural
production of testosterone because if you
inject a bunch of testosterone in your
body and you bring it over a certain
baseline when your body is like,
what the fuck is all this
task doing around here?
So your body says we don't
have to use the ball.
Shut the balls down so your body shuts
the balls down because you're squirting
into your body 10 times a
natural level of testosterone.
So you can get a 30 inch fucking arms.
You know the,
the,
when you see guys like that
and you watch them pose,
you ever see them pose?
Yeah.
They have the tiniest balls
you've ever seen in your life.
Like,
well,
I would be terrified if
my balls were that small.
And if you see those dudes
in those little lines,
m and m done,
I'm going to be their
balls or nonexistent.
It's like the ball's wither away.
I would love it.
I think my boss.
Do you have any
gross things that are
hanging from my awesome Dick?
You know,
I'd rather have two small little
cute ball things attached to it.
Then these big droopy old man throats,
I don't
know what the fuck man throw balls.
I have pretty average sized balls.
I'm not that.
Oh,
I don't have big Brah live.
He had elephant balls and you were like,
I gotta get rid of these elephant balls.
I'm happy with my balls.
I'm cool.
Scratching your balls as
best feeling in the world.
I used to think my balls were big until
I saw always balls and Joey Diaz his
balls.
Oh yeah.
And then I'm like,
yeah,
my balls are not that big.
Those balls were ridiculous to use.
It has huge pause.
But res has one that are
trying to escape his body ball.
It's like they looked like worms almost.
Well,
they sag way lower than
they're supposed to.
Yeah.
When our,
he pulls his balls out,
you're like,
what the fuck you,
you go to a doctor,
dude,
one day old and sagging.
Joey's balls look like
they belong on Joey.
You know everything
about him as a cartoon.
Cuban egg roll.
So of course his balls look like
softballs and old ladies pantyhose.
You know,
it's like,
that's what it looks like.
You would have this big giant ball,
one ball,
like a fucking speed bag.
Yo.
D as a classic.
He's a human like no other.
This is very few.
Joey Diaz is out there roaming the planet.
I always,
every time I seen him,
like,
why isn't there just a show?
Just following him around.
I know,
right?
He says this,
this weekend I was with them and like,
we're in the van going from the hotel,
two blocks go from the hotel to the venue.
You're in the,
like some people crossing the
street in front of everyone else,
kind of sit in the joy.
This,
hurry up your cock sucker.
I'm gonna take my fucking cock.
[inaudible] and the funniest formation
of words come together and everyone was
just cracking up.
I would like to see the things
that we don't know about Joe.
You know there's points
where he just sings,
you know,
opera songs,
cats,
man.
Most plasma ever.
Oh,
he's got all for these,
there's like three forums
and talk to a plasma.
He's out all three.
Four.
Yeah,
he's got it all.
You see I'm fucking eight cats.
[inaudible] cats in his house.
Didn't just get a new one.
You've got a new computer.
We've got 11 now.
I'm pretty sure it's in like
a two bedroom apartment.
11 cats.
Wow.
Dude.
I get a big house and I have
two cats and they drive me nuts.
These little motherfuckers
shitting all over the place.
It's annoying,
man.
My office smells like
cat shit all the time.
I always got a clue.
I was like cat shit cause they just take
stinky dumps in there and it's gross.
I've got to clean it out and fucking w
and then they take a shit an hour later
like you motherfucker,
I hate it.
So I'm taking out my
fucking house gets gross.
Right.
I hate it.
My place is so small and so I
had to have it in the kitchen.
So I'm like cooking last night and that
is my cat takes a shit and then it's
like,
you know fucking food mixed with Shit
and they spray it and then that now it
smells like a lemon forest full of shit.
They don't have like,
cause we don't,
I don't have,
I'm allergic to cats so we don't have,
but we have a neighborhood cats and
they always go in our back yard and they
shit.
No they shit.
And I never knew,
I never had cats so I thought cat
shit was like little like bunny shit.
Now it's like serious shit.
I'm constantly like snoop Dogg was here
and my cat has this thing where like
they pee on certain
sides of the litter box,
like the P my cat pees right in front
of the opening so it has to put it too,
but like right out the door of that litter
box and he had shit the other day and
just sprayed my wall was shit.
Oh God,
there's such dirty little animals.
And you know when you
let them out in the wild,
that's when you gotta be
worried about Toxoplasma.
Yeah.
That's when they catch it.
They catch it from,
from rats out in the wild.
So it'd become dangerous.
It can,
it can fuck with you.
And it's very dangerous
for little children.
Very dangerous for babies
and shit like that.
They're immune system's not ready for it.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Creepy fucking cats and dogs
aren't even better than I,
it's ridiculous.
Dog.
My dog lately has been digging up shit
and in the hiding bones in there and
putting it like just cartoon style,
like digging holes and it got in a fight
with like a possum the other day or
something like that.
And I don't even know what it had.
It looked like maybe a baby of some kind
all chewed up and brought it into the
house and just left it right
on these pee pads that we,
awesome baby possum.
I don't know what the fuck it was so tiny.
If your dog killed something and
it's gotta be little as fuck.
Yeah.
It's not,
what does your dog wait?
Like five pounds or something.
Eight pounds.
She's so small.
How could she kill anything?
What can she kill?
I think it was probably dead already,
but she decided to eat it,
but she brought it in and
Laid It on the pee pad.
Like she thought it was pooped.
So that's kind of cool.
But still it's like I don't want dead
corpses and fucking shit on my walls while
I'm cooking.
Keep the dog outside.
Well not that dog.
You can't a hawk come
and swap that sucker up.
And what if I were to buy a huge dog
house or make a dog house that was big
enough,
you know,
to let the dog stay in there for ever.
Listen man.
That dog needs people.
You've got a dog that needs
a lot of human attention.
You can't do that.
You can't leave.
We're outside.
So my crazy,
we've never been dogged
people and my are animals.
Like I never had animals.
My My,
my kid loves dogs and we thought
about for minute getting one.
But then I realized that I'd just be,
I'd have to take care of the dog
because my kids three years old,
he's not going to do it.
Kids will tell you,
oh,
I love dogs.
I'm definitely going
to take care of it dad.
Next thing you know you're walking that
fucking thing every day are my boy has
like he is just fearless.
She'll go up to any dog.
Like when he was like one and a
half we went to some family friends,
they had like a rottweiler big scary
looking and he was up there trying to kiss
it and we're like,
no,
no.
But he was just,
he goes for it.
I don't trust dogs.
Oh yeah,
no maybes.
Because they get confused
and think babies are dogs.
Oh my God,
that's the problem.
They don't associate
that with being a person.
So they'll,
they'll like check a baby just
to let a baby now you know,
like check a baby.
Like they were checking dogs.
Don't fucking my territory.
I've seen dogs do that before.
It's Carrie.
I was going to,
if you ever eaten at that place,
toast and on third over there and like
near West Hollywood is good but good plus
cause food and they uh,
we were going with a friend of mine and
go sit down one time and we're about to
sit in this,
this girl like five year old girl,
you know,
cute little blonde girl,
five year old and she's got
like a little bloody nose going.
And I was like,
oh poor girl fell or something.
And then as we're sitting we sit next
to this dog and the story comes out that
she was up there playing and the
dog bit it or knows and cutter.
Whoa.
And we're like,
okay,
we don't want to sit to this dog.
This dog was,
it was,
it looked like a regular,
it wasn't any kind of like,
it was like a,
it wasn't golden retriever,
but it was like a regular,
like it wasn't like,
like a month.
Yeah.
It wasn't anything to fucking girl.
And the face a girl,
I don't know what,
what she did or what happened
to the dog was still alive.
Nobody had beaten it to death.
Yeah.
You would think,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Bite a five year old baby.
Yeah,
you fucking cunt dog.
I'll kick you to death.
Yeah.
So I'm always worried with my son,
man.
He just went,
yeah,
you gotta be real careful.
It was right up there.
You got to always think that a dog will
consider your baby to be an animal.
Yeah,
they don't,
they don't consider it to be a person
cause it's not talking really in a real
little and they're high pitched voice.
It's like this is not the same thing.
I see Mazda Brawny he
could tell me what to do.
Well this is a little motherfucker.
Tell him,
tell him what's the deal,
bitch.
Fuck them up.
Try to take my food.
Tend to her dog for a bit.
Yeah.
I've had the worst week.
There's this bird that's
outside in my tree,
like the animal kingdom.
You had a cat,
a dog.
Now the bird,
this bird,
I don't know what it is,
but every time it gets dark it goes
through like 12 different chirp things.
Like it's like,
it sounds like somebody
breaking into a car,
Lawrence
and it keeps on doing it the whole
entire night to the bird call.
So I'm thinking about like poisoning or
slingshotting are shooting this bird.
I don't know what to do
because it's been all night.
You're Greek day this week.
You know how long you'd be
out there trying to slingshot
this break every window
and I bet you got some people
listen to the podcast too.
Like I know what that mother fucker lives.
It was him with that sling shot.
Yeah.
It's a horrible though.
I need to BB guns.
Bb guns are pretty accurate.
Yeah,
I was thinking about,
I can't even see it.
It's just this big.
That's what I'm saying.
That's just one of those
ideas you get in your head.
You're like,
I'm going to,
I'm going to put an end to this.
And then you ended up being like,
like Wiley Coyote or like Elmer Fudd.
That's how people like fall from trees
and break their neck and die trying to
kill some bird tweets outside your window.
Yeah,
I've,
I've had times when like,
I don't know if you guys
had like the mosquito,
the mosquitoes are worse than your
sleeping and then he like ignore it,
ignore it.
He keeps coming back like,
fuck it.
It's on lights.
Go on now you got to go around looking
for the mosquito against your white wall.
Like he disappears.
He reappears,
you're swinging shit.
Yeah.
Your eyes are trying to focus
my God fucking tears in them,
you know,
half hour later like,
fuck it man.
We don't realize how few bugs we have
in California until you go on the east
coast in the summertime and you
realize like go near a lake lake in the
summertime,
you're like,
mother fucker.
This is ridiculous.
Yeah.
But you know how cool lightning bugs was.
I do miss lightening bugs when you're
just going out in your backyard and just
like this glowing paradise.
But those are cool.
They don't,
but they don't bother you.
You know,
like smell grips,
I would say with,
with mosquitoes,
like they never have mosquitoes.
Mosquitoes,
not a fuckup paradise.
Whenever you book a trip,
you go down to Mexico and you're like,
oh,
this is great.
Here's the beer,
here's the Tequila,
whatever.
And like half an hour later
you start getting busy like,
and every time they showed those stupid
corona commercials where the guy like
throws his cell phone under the water,
I'm like,
show the fucking mosquitoes man.
It never that comfortable.
That's one of the good
things about Hawaii too.
Not Too many bugs in Hawaii that's make
that trip out to that volcano in the
middle of the ocean.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's not a bad,
Not that many bugs man.
But California as far as like no bugs,
this is probably as good as it
gets anywhere in the country.
You've got to Florida,
Florida is ridiculous.
I might as well be living in the jungle.
Yeah.
Cause there was an apartment building.
Doesn't mean it's not the jungle.
You've got a little pond next door
with a fucking alligator in it.
What's that?
They could be living in Gainesville.
You could be living in like a nice
part of town and take a couple blocks,
go for a walk and Oh,
what's this?
A dinosaur.
It's a fucking dinosaur poodle eating
dinosaur wander to the streets.
The Komodo dragons and monsters and
alligators are not that aggressive.
They're not nearly as
aggressive as crocodiles.
Crocodiles are really dangerous.
It's different.
It's an alligator and a crocodile.
The looks are different.
A crocodile,
their teeth like stick out of their
mouth a little bit and they have a longer
snout.
Alligators have like a
shorter stubbier wider snout,
but there.
But alligators in general
are bigger than crocodiles,
right?
No crocodiles,
they can get bigger.
I think maybe American alligators might
be bigger than American crocodiles,
but the biggest,
the biggest crocodiles
are the biggest of that.
That you know,
species that form similar though.
I mean Shit,
if you didn't know and you saw
an alligator and a crocodile,
you would say that's the same thing
like a Mexican and Guatemalan.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They don't look much different,
man,
but apparently they're,
they're way more aggressive.
Crocodiles are much,
much more aggressive.
Yeah.
I watched some documentary on alligators
and crocodiles and they had this place
in,
uh,
I believe it was in Florida where they
were raising them and they had all these
crocodiles,
this,
these alligators and one crocodile and
the crocodile would run over the top of
the alligators head when they would feed,
he would like be bitch,
just stepping over them
to get to the food.
Just super way more aggressive
than the alligators.
But in general,
you're right.
Like,
like I don't know how people like,
I mean,
once in a while we got like
mountain lions and stuff,
but generally speaking at,
you know,
how much you know with that suck if he's
just hanging out in a crocodile or an
alligator shows up in your backyard.
Now what he'd do,
well,
there was a funny story in Miami about
a guy who was running from the law and a
in a high speed chase ditches,
his car wipes his car out,
jumps into a fucking river and
wherever he was or jumped into a lake,
the moment he jumped in,
he got killed by an alligator.
Oh my God.
He just landed like right
next to an alligator and the
alligator jack them right
in front of the car on my God.
I mean,
it's a fucking movie that is hilarious.
Fucking movie.
The guy jumps out of the car,
dives into the water and right away,
boom.
Gets killed.
Yeah,
it happens.
Those cops are good man.
They got alligators working with them.
That's like,
I was actually,
I read when I,
it just meant I said the key.
Is it Kimono Komodo Dragon,
right?
Yeah.
Some guy read in the paper,
this guy was like on a boat or something
or he was surfing or something happen.
I think it was on a boat
and the shipwrecked.
So this poor guy swims to the
first piece of land he finds,
he swims to the shore and a
Komodo dragon confronts him.
I was like,
this poor guy.
Can you imagine?
Like,
it's like a video game.
It's like you survived the thing and I,
you still have,
you're like,
oh great,
now I kill him.
What's next?
You know?
You know,
did he,
I think he'd live
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
There was a guy who was a dating Sharon
Stone of Sharon Stone's boyfriend.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He was something like Moot newspaper
guy or something like that.
Yeah.
Apparently he was in a whole room
full of Komodo dragons at like a zoo.
We had white socks on and
the Komodo dragon mistook
his white foot for a rabbit,
so it just snapped down on his foot.
That guy's fucking screaming and the
poison that they have in their saliva,
they have botulism and all sorts of
horrible bacteria in their saliva,
and you get deathly ill from those bites,
like you have to go on some
radical antibiotics like
immediately or you're going
to die.
That's how it kills things.
The Komodo dragons bite things
and then just follow them.
Just infect them with
their saliva like they,
there's a video of one that kills a water
buffalo and it bites us water buffalo,
just Jackson and a leg and the water
buffalo runs away and then it slowly
follows it for a day while it poisons
itself slowly gets poisoned from that
bite.
It's fucking crazy lists that the,
those guide die or he lived,
he lived because they were right there
and they got the thing off of them.
They got it off his foot,
but you know,
he almost lost his foot.
That is crazy.
That stuff is there.
There is so dangerous to fucking,
they played by a whole
different set of rules.
So yeah,
65 million years ago,
these motherfuckers were roaming around.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
And animals.
And generally I was thinking about that.
That lady has seaworld that got that.
The whale that just took,
took her.
I mean,
can,
can you imagine?
I mean,
I can't,
Ooh,
it's terrifying.
Yeah.
You can't talk your way out of it.
Terrifying.
And the really terrifying thing about
the killer whale thing is that we know
that they're smart.
We know that they're intelligent,
they're not as smart as us,
but they're pretty God damn close.
They can't change their
environment like us.
And we show,
there's no evidence of them being able
to create things and build items like we
can.
But we know they have dialects.
We know that there are superintelligent
as far as their language and it varies
from sector to sector and we also know
that they're like incredibly attached to
their family and they have like this
really broad language that we don't even
totally understand.
So we know that there are these super
intense intelligent animals and we still
lock 'em up in swimming pools.
You know we just go,
fuck you.
I don't understand what you're saying.
What he's saying get in there.
Like if that thing was saying,
please I want to be with my mother,
please let me go.
You know,
if it could actually talk and
tell you what they really feel,
they would be screaming
in agony every night they,
they stuffed them into
these little tiny tanks.
It's like a refugee camp or something.
Yeah,
they make them perform.
One of the ways they make the performance,
stuffing them into these little tanks
at night to punish them and then now the
learn to jump so you can edit me.
People will clap for you.
You didn't want people to clap for you.
That's the swale.
It killed at least two
people to that is crazy.
He's killed at least two.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He doesn't want to deal
with their bullshit man.
You know he's right.
I see his point.
Fuck man.
If aliens came and they were smarter
than us and they just couldn't understand
us,
and we're talking to them like,
please,
we'll get our shit together.
We'll stop polluting the ocean.
Please don't fucking eat us.
And then they just started eating people.
They're like,
I don't understand you bitch.
So
yeah,
she's gonna throw you in the zoo.
The people's zoo.
And this guy's like the
revolutionary of Wales.
He's like,
the Che Guevara is busting out.
Yes.
I mean,
look,
I'm on team people 100% but we
should have totally rethink seaworld.
We should totally rethink anything where
super intelligent animals like that are
entrapped.
Yeah.
Feed them fish.
They're depressed.
They have to be.
There's no way it could be a
happy fucking in prison dolphin.
I mean,
it's pretty entertaining for your kids.
But,
but beyond that,
like I took my kid to the,
uh,
to the aquarium at Mandalay
Bay and he was two,
two and a half of that.
He was going,
he would see the shark.
He was shock.
Shock.
It would take my head I was holding,
he'd take my head and just twist
it to wherever the shark was.
I was like,
they should,
they should hire him out
at the front and be like,
you want a tour from this guy?
And he's just takes your
head shot a commercial.
Oh yeah.
That'd be a great commercial.
Right.
That would be a great commercial.
But that's different though.
That's fish.
Yeah,
that's true.
I go fuck themselves.
Right.
They're stupid.
They don't even take care of their,
they're young.
They just jerk off on eggs
and the eggs become babies.
I don't care about fish,
but dolphins,
I know that they can think,
oh yeah.
Oh,
you watched the cove you ever see?
Did you see the cove?
No,
I didn't see the co terrifying.
And you see the slaughter of Japanese,
the Japanese slaughter,
those stall fisherman.
So hard to watch,
man,
cause you know they're smart.
Dolphins are smart as fuck.
They're like little weird,
intelligent aliens.
Almost like little water elves.
Like they're playful little water ELLs.
They're super smart and they seem benign.
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm sure they have both sides,
but they seem very Dell rape view.
They'll rape you,
but you know,
they'll throw a rape it on your ass.
I'll try it out one.
Can you imagine that?
How do you come back and report a video
online of a woman getting humped on a
dock?
But Dolphins,
gadget guy.
He's a guy.
It's a gay dolphin.
Gay Rapist.
Dolphin.
That's great.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I think eventually we're going to have
to come to conclusion that zoos are
really cruel and inhumane punishment.
And there those are animal prisons.
Oh,
you've been to,
you've been to the La Zoo man zone.
It's just miserable.
Horrible.
It's the worst even open.
So it's walkable,
old ghosts parts.
Hey Bravo.
Fucked up and went to
the zoo on mushrooms.
Oh,
awful.
He said it was so sad.
He said it was like the saddest day ever.
I said all you could do,
you feel all the negative,
sad energy from these poor animals.
People staring at them and
the animals are usually,
it's,
they seem like every little display went
to like the animal was just looking for
shade.
Yeah.
He didn't want to entertain you.
He just in the corner somewhere looking
for shade and then they had like an
elephant thing and it was,
and it was in the back and they had like,
it didn't even make it.
The guy was like,
it's a long,
long walk.
So poorly thought out too,
because look,
human beings have a bunch of systems
that are put in place to ensure that we
breed to ensure that we succeed in life,
to ensure that we accomplish things.
There's all these things that are
set up in order for us to live.
You know,
the human way.
Well,
for animals there,
there's all these instincts
set up in their minds too.
One of the big ones is to kill things,
to kill things,
to survive.
You know,
they,
they get
that charge that,
I mean,
that's what it's fun for them.
That is what is the joy of life.
I mean it seems cruel and fucked up,
but the joy of life or aligns to take
out a gazelle and that's what it is.
That's what it therefore,
so if you're going to have real animals
and you're going to have them in these
locked down environments and pretend
that it's good for them and pretend that
it's a good environment,
you got to let them kill things,
man.
Yeah.
It's like,
um,
I went to Kenya once and they
have like the animal preserve,
so you just go in and they
say you actually kind of,
it's almost like you're going into
their turf now to check it out.
So it's not,
they're not caged,
but it's actually really interesting.
So you go somewhere in there.
They are just doing their natural thing.
It was a lot more natural,
it seemed.
The one thing was we were driving back
and we saw a rhino and we were in this
little like,
they give us this like
minivan and I don't mean to,
but yeah,
it was,
it was a,
it was this little van and
we had like this driver,
this Kenyan driver,
and he wasn't at all like,
you know,
he wasn't armed.
He didn't seem like he was,
he was there to protect us.
He looked like,
remember the guy,
the gods must be crazy.
I remember like the skinny,
it seemed like that's the guy that was
driving and there was like no defense
mechanism.
I'm like,
so this guy stops and where
there's like eight or nine of us,
you know,
all Westerners and this rhino
is like eating and we're like,
look,
Rhino Rhino.
And he looks up and he gives
us this like look of death.
Like it's almost like you just interrupt
this shook night in the middle of some
business meeting and,
and we all,
we all freaked out.
Like it was an intimidating look.
We're like,
go,
go.
And the guy's like,
like,
like Fred Flintstone.
He like get the car going.
Yeah,
exactly.
And our Fresno telling
us what these guys do,
I guess are colorblind
the rhinos and they,
and they just see something.
And if it,
if it's disturbing them,
they just run,
they would ramp,
they would've,
he would've rammed us
and they'll tip you over.
And now it's,
you know,
whatever,
however it plays out,
it plays out.
Either we all,
you know,
you all get stomped to death.
Some shit.
So pretty crazy dude.
Dead Rhinos in hippos are two of my
number one fears as far as animals go.
Hungry,
hippos,
hungry,
hippos.
I think you're responsible for more human
deaths in any other animal in Africa
other than ants.
Really believe aunts are responsible for
more human death in any item on answer
kill people.
Oh Shit,
dude.
[inaudible] in Africa,
they've got real problems with uh,
with giant swarms of poisonous ants.
Oh Shit.
Army ants and all these different,
there's,
there's so many really vicious aunts.
Especially like in the Amazon,
there's a thing called the bullet ants.
And,
uh,
they,
they actually use them for coming of age
ceremonies where they make these young
men stick their hand in these gloves
that are filled with these bullet ants.
Oh my God.
And he's bullet ants.
It's unbearable pain for
like 24 hours for each bite.
Oh,
like unbearable.
Like getting your hands slammed
in a car door all day long.
That is crazy.
Like insane pain and that's
like the coming of age thing.
Instead,
if a man can get through this,
he can truly be a match
to get benefit vendor.
But in Africa,
Brian Callan actually,
um,
was uh,
working when,
when he first got out of college he wanted
to work with insects and he wanted to
study them and overseas.
And one of the things
that scared him off his,
cause he went,
I think to Bornea he went to some crazy
fucking jungle and they had to put
Turpentine,
they all slept on platforms and they
had to put Turpentine all over the,
the legs of the platform.
And they have to be elevated above the
floor of the jungle because if you're
leave,
if you leave them on the floor of
the jungle and the ants come up,
once one ant bites you and sends a signal,
they'll,
there will be millions of ants on you,
poisonous ants on you and
you won't be able to stop it.
There's nothing you can do.
They will eat you alive fishing.
They take out elephants,
they climb up elephant's legs and they
climb in their ears and start eating
them.
I'm alive.
The more I hear things like this,
the more I realized like I just
want to go to four seasons.
I the world thing in burden
is be like the waffles day.
It's all good man.
I know some people are like adventures.
I we're going to go into
the jungle and did it on my,
you go camping bro.
I'll be at the four seasons.
You know
Brian said that date.
So they poured Turpentine all over
the legs of this platform that the,
they're,
they're sleeping on,
you know,
they have the hut and the
Hud is above the platform.
And he said in the night,
you can hear them marching.
He said,
there's so many ants in there,
so terrifying that you
can hear them marching.
You hear that?
That is creepy.
You hear millions and millions of answers
waiting to stumble on something and
whatever they stumble on,
whether it's a,
you know,
they'll,
they'll climb up a tree and find some,
uh,
some of the young birds that are
stuck in the Nast and smores,
millions of them.
So like there's a lot of jungles.
The,
the birds will try to put their nests
on the highest possible branch and a lot
of it is to avoid ants.
That is ridiculous.
Answer mother fucker.
That's like,
you know,
it's funny cause like when uh,
when you travel you realize
what you were saying.
Like it's like the,
the,
like the amount of stuff that's going,
like the,
the difficulty to live
in some other places.
Like when I went to Kenya,
we were for a wedding just just to get it,
just to go to Kenya.
You gotta go,
you gotta get like shots for dengue fever,
yellow fever,
jungle fever and all kinds of fever area.
Yeah,
I'll kind of malaria.
I was like it w what the fuck?
Where are we going?
Got To know.
I have yet to the motherland,
the order,
the motherland.
If we get some jungle feel
that
is the motherland too.
That's,
that's where it all began.
That's where human beings were hatched.
Yeah.
That's pretty crazy.
That now still so fucking wild.
It's crazy,
right?
When you look at Africa,
the continent,
like you ever watch like
those documentaries on
African and compare it to any
other constant continent in the world.
You're like,
what the fuck man?
You got willed the BC
lions and crocodiles,
saltwater crocodiles and fucking great
white sharks off the coast of South
Africa and it's Jesus Christ.
No continent is crazier than Africa.
I guess Australia is probably a close
and don't even get started on the flies
and how annoying that would be.
Your eyes just sitting on
your face all the time.
I was in Africa.
Yeah.
Whenever you see those poor starving kids,
it's one of the saddest
things about those videos.
The eyes they have covered
with flies and shit.
Fucked up.
What a fucking crazy place on earth.
I am obsessed with the Congo man.
I've got a bunch of
documentaries on the Congo.
One of the best ones is from the BBC.
But uh,
one of the most fascinating things about
the Congo is there's so many areas of
it they'd like people barely get to.
Yeah.
There's like this,
it's unbelievable how fucking dense it is.
And they,
in one point in time,
Europeans tried to settle it.
They tried to like build
these giant mansions and shit.
And some of them are still there,
like in frame,
but that just gets
swallowed up by the jungle.
It's just too wild.
It was crazy.
As you got,
you got,
you get nature and then you've
got like rebels fighting each.
I mean,
so you might survive the ants.
Are you going to be taken down
by the whatever the cognitive is,
rebel,
whoever,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a lot of problems because
they're fighting over resources.
There's a lot of minerals in the Congo
is a lot of minerals that they used to
make cell phones and shit like that.
It's a lot of,
that is where they harvested.
Okay.
Have you ever performed a South Africa?
You ever go?
You haven't?
Huh?
The two festivals I want to go.
No.
It's supposed to be pretty cool.
Sure it is.
I'm tired of traveling,
man.
I enjoy going to the UK like once a year,
but even that,
it's like enough.
I go to Australia once.
He,
no,
I hear you too much sick.
I'm sick of the trap.
I mean,
I'd be curious to see it,
but I mean,
it's funny because people ask like the
fun part of stand up is actually being on
stage and doing a show and I'd
rather just drive up the block,
the sun,
so to Bray go and just get on a plane.
Well,
we're in a great
by two because we can work
so many places around here.
You can go to a comedy
magic club in Hermosa Beach.
You go to the ice house,
you can go to San Diego,
you can go to,
you know,
you can go to Irvine,
you get a Bray and you can go to Ontario,
you can do all the Improv.
So you could do,
I mean,
and you rotate all these clubs and after
awhile you just start back up on the
first one again.
You know,
it's like 1520 weeks later.
Yeah.
And then just doing these same
clubs over and over again.
Performing side of fs,
South African,
you just clam claim,
you can't,
I can't help you.
South Africa is a,
I'm sure it's a great place.
I like DMT were,
yeah,
okay.
They got good music.
I mean,
you know,
actually I was district nine too.
I was thinking of going,
I mean I,
there was like an offer to go this summer
and I was thinking as I always say,
cause I've got two young
kids now and my wife's,
I was like,
well maybe I'll just
take everybody with me.
And I was like,
well that made me think
the nanny to to Africa.
I do it.
I started doing the math.
I'm like,
I would be like losing a lot of money.
Just like screw it,
we're going to stay here.
Chevy Chase.
Yeah,
you must have a big international
following now because you,
you've really become like as far as like
would you call it the Persian community
or the area
learning community.
But you know the Persian committee is
like my first probably it's funny like a
like triple e one time Santa Trivia.
It was like,
he's like,
you're like the Persian Elvis,
otherwise known as pelvis.
So that sounds like a triple e line.
Right.
So so I,
so that,
that's like my,
like you got,
you got the Persian middle easterners,
then you got like Arabs,
you know,
and then,
and then after that like then like you've
got like NPR types that are into like
world.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
I'm telling you man,
I love the fact that you're different.
It's actually pretty funny though.
It's,
well it's actually good to like do stand
up in front of people that know the
difference between Iran and Iraq.
You know what I'm saying?
As opposed to like doing it in
front of someone who is like,
what the fuck?
You know,
it's all the same.
She is blow it up,
you know?
So no,
it's,
it's so,
so it has become a thing.
What happened was in oh seven,
uh,
when we were still doing the acts of evil,
me,
I'm at an Aaron,
we went out to,
and this is a tour that you guys,
we have to oppose us of evil comedies.
I see evil comedy tour.
It was,
it actually originally started with Mitzi
shore who put us together and call it
the Arabian nights.
This was in 2000.
She put us to the Arabian nights
and Iranians aren't Arabs.
So we'd do shows and like inevitably like
Iranians would come up afterwards and
be like,
it was a good show,
but a,
we're not Arabs.
And I was like,
I know.
And He,
Ronnie's a very sensitive about that.
I actually read a national
geographic article,
this,
this journalist went any Ron.
I said I was interviewing
people and he goes,
I asked people,
what do you want the
world to know about you?
He said,
the first thing they would
always say is we're not Arabs.
The second thing,
we're not terrorists.
So it's like it's better to be a
terrorist in an Arab in their mind.
You know,
that's kind of in America,
we know so little about Iran other than
the Iran hostage crisis and that you
guys are trying to get nuclear power
and blow shit up all the negative shit.
Exactly,
exactly.
And then we know about this most
recent almost take over the government.
Yeah,
the green,
the green movement was supposed the cause.
What happened was in oh nine there was
elections and there was obviously voter
fraud.
Um,
but they uh,
so then there was protests in the streets.
Actually that was kind of,
that was the first time where I had
Americans coming up to me going like,
wow,
there's so many beautiful women.
Like they're like,
cause the protesters,
there was a lot of women in them
and there was dudes in jeans.
So people would come up and go like,
oh,
aren't they supposed to be
wearing burkas and turbans?
I'm like,
no man.
Toronto is an international city.
Of it.
Yeah,
I ran is much more sophisticated and
much more ahead than we've been led on.
I mean,
we've lumped them in with like Pakistan
and Afghanistan and even those,
I mean like Afghanistan,
it's probably the,
the one that's like the least developed,
you know.
But even those countries,
like if they have a lot of western
influences and also a lot of,
you know,
especially with technology and stuff
now there's a lot of people that are
advanced in this country,
especially if you going to a major city,
you know,
you're going to see it's
the hustle and bustle.
You're going to see some dude driving.
A Mercedes Benz is a multimillionaire
and you can see some dude like pushing a
cart who's making five
bucks a year or something.
You know what I'm saying?
So this,
this exists,
but it's like,
I think a lot of people's image of the
Middle East is just dudes and turbans and
women in Burkas.
And it's like,
first of all,
the Burka is like,
you know,
is,
is pretty exclusive to like,
uh,
Afghanistan where they would wear the,
you know,
the full thing with the blue thing under
the Taliban where they had to cover
themselves and they could just barely see.
I like that Little Mesh.
I love that shit.
I would love my girlfriend
and where that shit,
it could be kind of sexy.
That's
the weakest pimp move.
No,
no,
no.
Cover everything.
Even your nose.
Yeah.
I let her keep it.
Cut The tits out or something and
just saying that would be fine.
Just the size.
What's the stars over the netball?
She had market that online.
See people buy it.
I think you found your niche,
your niche,
a burqa,
burqa,
sex,
gay sex clothes.
There was a woman at the mall in Texas.
I was in Texas recently and there's a
woman at the mall that was in full gear.
All they could see was
her eyes and I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
She's really going,
you know,
she's going fucking biblical.
That's Texas.
That's hot.
That's what we did,
actually
did a show in Saudi
Arabia with Ahmed and uh,
and uh,
you know,
after the show,
a lot of people that come to our shows
are either they'd be the travel in the
west,
are their western educated or their ex
pats so you don't have to show taking
pictures and all the people coming up.
And this one girl came up in one of those,
it's like she was fully covering stuff
for the eyes and she took a picture with
us and I was like,
what the fuck?
Like no one's gonna like,
it's like you could be anybody.
It has like that Superhero Vida.
Like you don't know who this person is.
You don't have to kind of take off their
burger and in most beautiful woman in
the ride,
you know,
I love that subservient to you.
Right.
You and only you,
he actually washes your feet.
She brings me no,
it's fun.
It's funny.
It's funny
because actually in d cause so now,
so you've got,
so you've got the burka,
which is Afghanistan and he got like
the veil kind of thing with the ice
covered,
which is like a Saudi
Arabia do that a lot.
Then like in Iran you get some that are
religious that will cover like their
hair and everything,
but you see the full face.
Then you got like Dubai,
we've got,
you've got these girls is ridiculous.
They uh,
they were the like the thing and um,
and,
and but it's all like,
they're blinged out.
Like you'll see,
you'll see like designer shoes does.
Even the,
even the thing that covers him,
they'll put like a little
diamond studs on them and stuff.
Real.
It's the weirdest thing.
Yeah.
And then do it,
it's actually,
they're,
they're pretty cute.
Like they'll take like [inaudible] and
then there's this become this thing there
now where like the women,
it's weird,
like they want their,
like the hair to seem like it's puffier.
So they'll take like a can like thing
like this and they'll roll hair up in a
bump and then they put it there.
So it looks kind of,
it looks very like star wars.
He,
you know,
princess in Star Wars,
they might as well be star wars.
He would those crazy robes.
B One Kenobi.
Shit.
Yeah,
it is.
It is some Obi Obi wan Kenobi.
Actually,
you know what the Obi wan Kenobi,
you know what I was in?
Um,
I went to Morocco just to travel,
not to do shows.
This was years ago.
I went to Morocco and we went to Fez,
which is the coolest place.
The Fas cap comes from that,
you know,
the first cap,
the like the like that
with a little thing.
Anyway,
and they told us,
I went there with,
now my wife who was in my
girlfriend and she had been,
she was studying in the south of Spain,
so we'd like took a boat over
and we had no preparation.
Like you should,
you should research before you go.
So we're like on our way on the boat,
we're reading this like
little guidebook and it goes,
whatever you do,
don't accept a guide because they're
going to infest they're gonna try and come
up to you and want to be your,
and talk to the hotel to get you a guide.
We didn't have it.
We didn't have a hotel.
Like we didn't know where
we're going to stay.
And My,
and my girlfriend at the time,
it kept saying that.
She said,
um,
my wife that she's like,
we need to go to the old city.
That's really,
I supposed to be really nice.
The Old City.
Now I don't speak Arabic,
I speak Farsi.
So I had no idea.
You say old city in Arabic,
but the Moroccans,
they speak French.
I take,
I take it three years of French.
So the whole time in the train I'm like,
how do you say Old City and French?
I'm like,
is it less sita?
You know?
Vecchio you know,
I was like,
that's not it.
So I finally asked him,
dude,
he's like,
oh,
[inaudible] v means the
ancient city lost the old veal.
So,
so our plan was just land in Fez,
find a cab and say,
take us to [inaudible].
So we're getting a cab and the cab
drivers like where in the luncheonette and
lost the Advil.
And I'm like,
just [inaudible] you know,
he's like a hotel.
I'm like,
yeah.
I was like,
oh,
they just go to some hotels.
So the do takes us a,
we go into the ancient city and
then right when we get there,
some guy like flags him down.
He comes,
the dude walks over the passenger side
and leans his head in his says something
in Arabic to the,
to the driver.
And then he leans to us,
he goes,
hello,
I will show you.
You look for hotel.
He sounded like,
borrow it.
I sorta got you look for hotel.
Uh,
and we're like,
uh,
no,
we're okay.
He's like,
no,
I will show it.
Don't worry.
And he got into the car.
I'm like,
Shit,
we're getting kidnapped.
And he takes us to some like,
like,
like the,
they have these like old homes
that have turned into hotels.
It was really nice,
but like nobody was staying there.
So he takes us there anyway,
so he becomes our guide unintentionally.
He's now our guide,
told them those or avoid,
I've told my wife,
I'm like,
Shit.
Now we've got a guide,
like how do we tell him no?
He's like,
don't worry you don't.
I show you around if you like,
then maybe you can give some leading
me like bring up the money thing and he
says,
he's like,
let me take you here.
Then he said,
let me take you kick that
motherfucker right out of there.
It's one of these situations
though where you're like,
okay,
this guy's a local.
He kind of,
I mean you feel intimidated
because you like,
they know each other somehow.
Like,
I don't want to let you just,
you kind of like,
let's go along,
but just be ready to run at any minute.
So we ended up in some,
he's like,
let me take you for dinner.
We go to this restaurant.
I'm not kidding.
There was like balloons and banners.
All this shit was up,
but there was no one.
We were the only two eating
in the restaurant and the
waiter comes to the waiter
was so excited to see us.
He's like,
hello,
hello.
And it's like the waiter was the
waiter slash the cook slash the owner.
Like he would like go cook in the back
and they come sit and watch us eat.
It was the craziest shit.
Wow.
But the OBI wan Kenobi Shit,
those crazy is these guides.
They actually were the
Obi wan Kenobi like the,
the gown with the hat,
like during the day they wear it.
And that's the official like fairs,
like guide outfit like that.
Like that's an official guide.
Like the government I think
recognizes them as guides.
And the weird one when I realized
it was Obi wan Kenobi and I,
and I was like,
I was like,
George Lucas must've come to fairs and
come up with this because my wife and I,
the next day she got the guy goes,
I'm going to show you the castle today.
And we're like,
alright.
So he takes us to like the castle.
He's like,
okay,
I cannot come close.
You Go,
I come,
I see you at other sides.
I guess they don't let the guides come.
So should we go?
We take a picture too.
And then we're like how's it going?
I'm going to find us.
And we start walking and across the,
and I'm looking for the guy literally
across the street in one of those Obi wan
Kenobi.
Cause that's what he's shown up with
Obi wan Kenobi off is like with the hood
on.
He's kind of cross the street watching
us nodding and he's like keep walking.
So he kind of kept an eye on us
and you know how like in Star Wars,
like ob one was kind of weird like that,
like,
like disappeared.
So I was like,
I was like George Lucas must've come here
and gotten a guide and then it came up
with the fucking Obi wan Kenobi.
Wow.
That's so weird.
So how long has this guide outfit existed?
Dude,
the guide outfit was,
is like day day outfit and
then by night he would show up.
Kind of dress regularly.
But whoa,
that's so strange.
How long did he,
you ask how many years
they'd been doing this?
I said,
we ain't turn tradition.
We,
I didn't ask him about that.
I didn't ask him about the outfit.
I just,
I just realized there was a bunch of
guys with the outfit around like it was,
it was basically you'd have like your
clothes underneath and you just throw the
robot and it's almost like,
yeah,
it's almost like,
you know,
like a judge.
Like they just put it over.
Did you ever have a pet
monkey that robbed you?
There was a pet monkey to rock.
There was,
it's funny you say that
because they actually,
first of all,
they do have pet monkeys
out there that like,
like um,
do,
do tricks and stuff.
But what he did was he took us
to a rug store that he's like,
you want to see rugs?
And I'm like,
and at the time I was
living in with my mom,
like I was dating my girlfriend,
but I was living with my mom
and I didn't have an apartment,
so I had nowhere to put rugs.
I was like,
no,
I don't need a rug.
He's like,
dude,
just come.
We look at the rug,
you know?
And so finally,
like we go into this place,
these guys,
the Moroccans are the
biggest sales people.
Like they will like,
they will fucking,
they will push you to
you buy like the guy,
he came Isaac like you want,
I look at the rugs,
I was like,
I don't really want to look at right.
He's like,
just look,
it's okay.
So,
and then they bring you up mint tea.
So now I'm looking at my girl.
I'm like,
Oh,
this is fun.
They're going to give us free tea.
And all we gotta do look at some rugs.
And he's like,
okay,
out of these 10 we'd do like,
I'm like,
Aww.
Those are kind of Nice.
He's like,
okay,
I give to you for,
you know,
whatever,
$5,000.
I'm like,
dude,
I don't have a place to put them.
He's like,
okay,
which three do you like?
It was like,
I don't want any,
he started negotiating.
I didn't even know I was negotiating.
Finally.
I'm like,
okay,
first of all,
I'm waiting for my,
for,
for her to bust in with like,
look dude,
we don't want to fuck a rose.
But she's just sitting there going like,
she's think cause later on I asked her,
I was like,
why don't you bust?
And she's like,
I thought you're the man
you're going to take.
I was like,
no,
you've got to come in.
It's like the tight ass.
And then finally,
um,
what was funny was I was like,
oh I got,
I got the Trump card here because it was
literally in some back alley with like
bike,
like barely,
like they barely had like,
like,
like the door,
like you know,
it was all old school.
Like,
like the bells.
Like when there was like nothing
technical about the place.
I'm like,
I got the Trump card right here.
I'm just going to let the dude,
no,
I got no cash bro.
I got credit cards and I said that.
And he's like,
we have credit card machine went and got,
those are the old roller,
you know,
the old thing.
And,
uh,
and then,
and then they fucking,
they sold me three rugs.
I'm not kidding.
And the funny thing is,
um,
the shift it to the America
and I'm not kidding,
I had no place to sit up
to put them for six months.
I drove around with three rugs
in my trunk and I was just like,
I like,
I gave him a way to relatives
that had apartments.
Like I actually have started to talk
about it in a standup and I go like,
for six months I was going around
trying to sell it to relatives,
you know?
No,
you just look,
have some mint tea,
you know,
but that's how they get you mad.
But it's like,
what?
That's like we,
you know,
1200 bucks,
man,
1200 bucks.
I was like,
I have no idea of what they were.
I don't know if they're worth it.
I have no idea.
He scored.
He scored on you.
Oh yeah.
They ate for,
for a month.
It's funny how many cultures
there are like that,
that barter and you know,
like,
you know,
try to get you to buy
things on the street.
Oh yeah.
Street peddling is like a big
part of a lot of cultures.
Oh yeah.
That freaked me out when
I first went to Tijuana.
Oh yeah.
I'd never seen that before in and mass
where people just selling everything in
the street.
Every,
this was like way back in.
Then I went with wheels.
Oh yeah.
Wheels were Dreezy.
Yeah.
Wheels per easy.
We're doing the comedy store
in La Jolla and wheels.
Didn't even know how to get there.
I go.
Do you know how to go there?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know.
I didn't know where the fuck he was going.
I'm like,
how do we get back to him?
I go,
yeah,
I'm not sure.
Totally lost no navigation systems,
but this is like the
late nineties and Shit,
you know?
No one knew where you were a lost man.
I was like,
we gotta get the fuck out of Mexico.
I was in Mexico.
I was in Tijuana for 20 minutes.
I was like,
this is crazy.
It's like,
I couldn't believe this stark contrast
between San Diego cross the border.
All of a sudden you're in a third world.
Whoa.
Like this is,
this is hookers everywhere.
You know,
girls walking the street
and you see guns open,
open guns.
He was like so many creepy little fucking
spots and we were driving around these
little weird cities and
I'm going to Toyota,
super a turbo shiny little looking like
an la Douche bag looking like a victim
and the federal Raleigh's look for you.
That's the problem in these places is
the cops or even you got to look out for
the cops.
They're trying to rob you,
man.
I had that in Mexico where the guy,
cause then what they do is like,
first of all,
you walk into like the Mexican,
the Mexican bazaar.
I went into like,
there was nobody there.
It was a dead.
It was like middle of the day.
No one's there.
And I walk in and the guy's like,
hey,
you want to buy like a bag or whatever.
You want to buy a shoes?
I'm like,
no,
it's all right.
He's like,
I bought some weed.
I'm like,
no,
he's like cocaine.
I'm like,
no.
And then then he's like fucking pussy.
Like they like turn on.
You're like,
what happened man,
we were Bros,
you
fucking pussy.
Just cause I don't want your heroine.
Maybe we gotta get Outta here man.
Yeah,
Mexico is a trip you place.
It's so strange that it's connected.
You know,
and people don't,
don't seem to recognize that threat.
The fact that it's connected the oxen,
they actually said that
this Mckean just came out.
Not,
not that this means anything,
but McCain just came out and said that
giant forest fire they have going on
right now and at an Arizona,
you know about that,
right.
Huge out of control wildfire.
And they think it was started by
illegal immigrants setting up camp.
Oh Wow.
You know,
there's a lot of guys,
they crossed the border in Arizona said,
you know,
we'll do a campfires and shit and
just forgot to put the campfire out.
Shit.
Giant fucking 140,000 Acre wouldn't it?
How acres it is now.
That's crazy.
It's insane.
But it's uh,
I'm actually scheduled to do some
show in Mexico like in the fall.
And what's funny is like,
you know,
people are always scared of
the Middle East and stuff,
but like my wife and I
were talking about like,
you know all these kidnappings and
stuff going on in Mexico and it's like,
is it worth going down there and you know,
I'm thinking about the
same thing like Cabo.
I was just thinking of
going somewhere in Mexico,
but is it even worth going?
I heard that if you go to resorts,
you're fine.
My friend Matt just got back from Cabo.
How goes to cobble all the time?
He loves it.
It's a combo.
Supposed to still be nice,
but there's Acapulco,
which is real dangerous now.
Aga bogos supposed to be dangerous.
Can't coons supposed
to be a little tricky.
They've for the most part,
avoid the resort towns.
They don't want,
didn't want to fuck up
business for everybody,
but in Acapulco they've
Jack People in resorts.
Yeah,
I could.
Poco was apparently
pretty shady right now,
but a cabo is supposed to be still good.
I was in Cabo was good.
It was a nice resort.
It's actually funny.
Before all this was kind
of going on like five,
six years ago I went to Cabo and we were
staying at the Hilton and it was a nice
place and it was Kinda,
it was kinda funny cause he's,
cause everyone's out there obviously,
you know tourists and the bathing
suits and these two dudes showed up.
It was like the,
it was,
it was like keystone cop.
It wasn't keeping me was like,
it was like bumbling idiot criminals.
They showed up.
These two guys with,
with empty bags,
like duffle bags almost a with their
shirts off as if they're tourists with
genes obviously not tourists.
Like,
and the reason these two Mexican
dudes walking around the pool,
like just checking shit out.
It like look at least walking around
looking for a place to like they start
snatching things and I,
and I looked at my wife,
I was like,
did those guys seem like they fit in here?
She's like,
no.
It was like,
I better tell somebody and
went over till the management.
Like those two dudes don't look like
their hotel clients and the next thing you
know they're getting escorted out.
They walked in,
but it's like they did not buy
or invest in a bathing suit.
So you see,
look,
the part,
they were in there with their jeans,
with their shirts off,
you know,
obviously not,
just did not fit in at all.
It's weird how quickly it's changed.
I went on vacation in
Cancun I think in like 2000,
2001.
And uh,
I wouldn't even think
about going there now.
Yeah,
it's too bad too.
There's so many spots I want to see.
Oh,
I want to see all sorts of,
uh,
the Mayan ruins.
So many did plume and uh,
you know,
I've been to Cheech and EATSA and
there's ones outside of Mexico City.
I would love to see them.
I mean,
they're incredible.
I guess there's that,
that exhibit in Caba,
that underwater,
uh,
art exhibit.
Have you seen it where it's just a bunch
of statues underneath the water and you
can go down there?
I think it's scuba dive or do something
like that where there's just this huge
art piece underneath the ocean recently.
Someone's put,
yeah,
yeah.
And I guess if you're a good artist,
they will let you add your own work to it.
Like if you're real hard.
So it's Kinda cool.
So all these really good artists have
been adding things to it and I guess it's
just amazing.
And the only way you can get to this,
why scuba diving?
I think so.
I'm not sure.
I'm not,
I'm not sure about that part,
but that's what I kind of guessing.
Maybe it's a boat.
Yeah.
Well that's cool.
They've got to write that country,
man.
They've got to figure it out.
They did with Columbia,
they straightened Columbia.
Columbia,
apparently you can travel there now.
And it used to be,
you know,
back in the 80s when the
cocaine crisis was going on,
Columbia was just ridiculous.
You know,
Metta,
Ian was a Goddamn war zone,
but now apparently you can go to Columbia
and like they've taken care of shit.
They've cleaned it up.
But I don't know if they're ever going
to be able to do that with Mexico.
It's just,
it's so close to the supply.
You know,
the,
the cash supply of America
is like right there.
They can get the drugs and you know,
get that shit across quickly and they're
doing crazy shit like rolling heads
into disco techs and shit.
You heard about that kill people enroll?
Ha.
I mean at what point do you go,
I killed them.
I cut off his head,
rolled it.
That's the role that a discotheque,
the other thing I've been thinking of is,
I guess it Chapin is so
broke right now that,
that it's so cheap to
fly to Japan right now.
They need people to come to
Japan because no one's going now.
And so I heard that there's like flights
for like ridiculous amounts of money
from La,
like 300 bucks or something
like that just to go to Japan.
Wow.
And I'm like,
now would you go to Tokyo?
Would you do that?
Or is it doesn't do anything about it.
Read up on what the levels
are as far as radiation goes.
But the problem with Japan
and the radiation is that
I don't think they've been
entirely honest about it.
Yeah.
I don't think they've been
honest about the leak.
You know,
there's,
they're finding out that all
three of them are melt throughs.
They're there,
they're finding out all sorts of things
where it turns out that the actual
damage done by these,
you know,
nuclear disasters is far,
far greater than what they
had initially forecast.
And so who knows,
like how far the spread
of the radiation goes.
I would have to hear about that.
It'd be a fucking shame to go there for
$300 ticket and just fucking nuke for a
bargain,
get bigger balls.
I would love to go to Japan though,
man.
I've always wanted to go.
I was always hoping that
we'd do a UFC in Japan.
It's such an amazing piece of history.
You know,
that one part of the
world is so unique there.
There are innovations as far as martial
arts go and swordsmanship and literature
and you know,
I mean that's where the book
of five rings came from.
What the book of five rings is one of
my like guidebooks for life that me and
Martin was hace book and that's,
you know,
all that Samurai way,
all that shit came from Japan.
It's amazing culture.
It does seem like a pretty crazy and they,
and it feels like after,
I don't know how they
were before World War II,
but it feels like after World War II
they became more capitalistic than we are
even,
you know,
like if you see like any
footage I've seen ever,
it's like,
you know like the neon lights and the,
and just like the,
the amount of like the Japanese and
the products they love and you know,
it's just,
I don't think there is
materialistic as us though.
I don't think they purchase
things and own things.
I don't think there's a lot of emphasis
in their culture of owning things.
Okay.
I think they spend all their money going
out to eat and spend all their money
drinking and spend makeup and different
and you notice also knows that a lot of
them I have all have like eyelashes,
fake eyelashes and they
spent so much money.
Women,
men started rock and
fake eyelashes as well,
how to do it.
It's kind of,
they kind of did,
they spend a lot more
money on how they look.
Like I saw the other day.
What did Americans,
I saw the,
at the saddle ranch I saw a group,
I'm like no step is research
seven kids for sure.
There were a few Asian pan.
Well I had whatever,
same shit.
They all had their hair done
with like the brown in the debt,
that blonde streaks in it and
they all had had like their,
their genes that probably costs them $300.
They do.
I've always said the Japanese seem
to be the most European of Asians.
Like they're very much into like,
like you said,
it's kind of a diff,
it seems like a different look.
You know there are little
like hipper in their way.
You know what I'm saying?
Is it mixed with hairstylist?
It's interesting.
Interesting how many Japanese
people are into American culture.
Oh yeah.
How much they follow it and are really,
really,
you know,
enamored by Elvis.
Michael Jackson was
like superman for them.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
It's a fascinating culture.
You know when they had all these problems
with the tsunamis in the earthquake
and everything like that,
and people would wait in line for a,
for food and water and rations,
they were orderly as fuck,
man,
they're culture is like so polite.
They told me that they went to a bar or
something in Japan and people were lined
up like at the bar as opposed to like
the idea of just come at the bazaar
mentality.
Right.
That's pretty crazy if
you think about that.
Yeah.
They're,
they're much more disciplined,
much more discipline and humble.
Did you ever see Babel,
the movie babble babble.
Now it is it.
Oh,
it's a great movie.
Nri to the director.
Do you ever see I'm Otis Pedro's,
you know what?
No.
With the dog fighting and all that,
I bought on DVD and I
put it down somewhere.
I have to get in the mood to
watch a movie with subtitles,
but dude,
he's intense.
He's a great director.
He's done.
He'd done a,
I've seen a few of his movies.
I think he,
I think he also did 21 grants.
I might be,
I might be mistaken,
but I think you're right.
So he's got like the movies,
I've seen him do all have like two
or three stories and they all kind of
intertwined somehow.
And this one Babel was amazing and
it had like three stories going on.
One of them was,
uh,
it's a,
Brad Pitt and um,
and not Naomi Watts,
but,
but um,
I forget her name.
Anyway,
they go to,
they go to Morocco and they're
visiting Morocco and uh,
and some shit goes down and then,
and then,
and then there's another story of a
Mexican family who's trying to get to a,
a,
a wedding,
I think across the board.
And then they get into some trouble.
And then there's a story
of this Japanese girl,
this is what I'm talking about.
The judge,
you have anything.
It's so amazing.
This girl,
I think she should've won the Oscar
for best supporting actress that year.
She plays a,
she plays a deaf girl who's like just
depressed and living with her dad and this
stuff.
And she's just as an actor,
like,
I don't know how you play deaf.
And I don't know how
you'd do it that well,
like it's the most amazing thing.
And what was really cool about it was,
so this girl was like a party girl,
like having a good time with her friends,
but she's depressed.
And what was this intense scene where
like they're out there partying.
I think they do ecstasy or
something and they end up at a,
at a nightclub.
And it's the coolest thing because
suddenly it goes from her perspective.
Imagine that from a deaf
person's perspective,
a nightclub.
So like,
it's like,
it's like really loud,
but she's not hearing the whole
thing is just kind of like,
it's like muddled and she's kind of
looking around as the most intense shit.
I'm kind of getting goosebumps
thinking you got to see it.
What's it called again?
It's called Babel B.
A.
B.
E.
L.
It has a great soundtrack too.
And,
and um,
and,
and this seen,
this girl killed it and
she ended up losing to,
um,
uh,
Hudson.
Jennifer Hudson from a,
a dream dream girls was at
the movie and I saw her,
I saw some of that.
I didn't see the whole thing and that,
but I think that she won
because it was like a popular,
like she sang in that.
I mean,
I'm sure there's some good acting in it,
but this girl just knocked it out like
as an actor to sit there and watch
somebody kill it like that.
You're like,
Damn,
you know?
And,
but it was all Japan and it was,
it was pretty cool.
It's a cool,
like kind of like a night in Japan.
Kind of such an unusual culture,
man.
Yeah.
It's a really crazy place.
They invented the suicide bombing too.
They invented the advent of the kamikaze.
We know what they did.
They got people on Crystal Meth.
Really?
Yeah.
That's a,
that's how they got them
to do kamikaze work.
Gave him crazy amphetamines and
made him just fucking do nutty shit.
Crazy is that,
you know,
what's interesting is
when you realize like,
that's,
that's good to know.
Like,
like when you realize sometimes
the motivation behind some things,
like my dad before he passed,
so he used to tell me that a
lot of the mullahs in Iran,
um,
they,
they're like a lot of people in,
you're on smoke opium,
it's like smoking weed but it's opium.
And he was saying that a lot of
these molars actually smoke opium.
And I ended up doing a bit about,
uh,
you know,
staying up about how the reason these
guys are talking shit to America's cause
they're high and suddenly
started making sense.
Like even like Kadafi supposedly
it's just high on all kinds of meds.
And so you realize why the guys out
there talking like it's fucking Tony
Montana.
I don't know if you've
seen some of the quotes,
but he's like,
I'm gonna fight to the death.
So you know,
somebody might give them like,
credit is like,
I mean his followers would
be like kipp credit for like,
oh,
this guy's got balls,
he's stand up to America.
But no,
the guy's fucking high.
And he's just talking shit.
And the same thing with
these guys that are kamikaze.
You know,
it was like,
Oh wow,
there's a lot of balls to do that.
Yeah.
If you're fucking high on meth.
He like,
yeah,
I think I'm about to fucking take on
this fucking boat with my little plane.
I just saw a movie,
guys.
Remember that movie airport?
It was big in the seventies
I was kind of a report.
Yeah.
It was about a terrorism
act that this guy,
this guy lost his job.
The economy was shit and he
was going to kill himself to,
to collect on insurance.
And so he went on this plane and it was
kind of cool to see like how planes he
used to be,
where people are smoking,
you know,
and,
and all this crap.
And then he blew up a bomb on the plane
and it was so funny seeing how na Aa,
how we used to think if a
bomb blew up on a plane,
like how this little hole came out
and the wind blew around the little,
it's like,
oh,
it's windy in here.
You know,
like the plane's not special effects
in the ground or anything like that,
but do,
it was also weird just seeing
like how the airports are cured.
He used to be how like how the movies,
like this one was a movie about a
terrorist blowing up a bomb in 19,
whatever,
79 or [inaudible] 72 or something.
I think it was even earlier than that,
but they made a four movies about it.
I don't know if you guys ever
was,
it was,
this was actually an actual thing that
happened and it was based on a true
story.
There's no,
no,
this is just like the,
the,
their take of terrorism back in the 70s
and like bombs and blowing up the planes
or interest terror in 1970 it was,
there was some terrorism back then,
you know,
I mean there had been,
uh,
that,
that event that happened
at the Olympics Olympics.
Yeah.
What year was that?
[inaudible] 72 [inaudible] 72 Olympics.
I mean,
we've had terrorism forever.
Oh yeah.
Well,
they say even like if you go back to
like the whole Jewish Palestinian thing,
like before,
before Israel became a state,
the Jews were doing terrorist
acts to try and get,
you know,
to,
to get more locks.
Yeah.
You get more locks.
No,
I mean it always,
and uh,
an oppressed people are always doing
the terrorist shellacked you know.
Um,
but,
um,
but no,
but that,
that,
uh,
the,
the thing with the,
with the,
with what you talking about
air travel and stuff now,
even now when you travel,
when you go to different
parts of the world,
it's amazing to see their take on
terrorism and there take through like the
airport,
like say like,
well,
I've just seen,
like,
I've been,
I've been to airports now sometimes in
the Middle East where the dude's like
straight up.
Like,
like he's talking on his phone as you're,
like,
the Tsa guy is on an earpiece,
talking on a phone,
just like it.
Go ahead.
And I was joking,
I was like,
he's like,
go ahead.
You know,
you,
you know,
you can go because,
because,
you know,
we're,
we're all terrorists.
Like,
you know,
that that was my take of it jokingly.
But like I've had that,
you know,
I've had,
I've had dudes like on the
phone not paying attention.
I had,
I saw one TSA dude literally like he was,
he was kind of,
um,
he,
he kinda like moved out of the way.
Uh,
and he was checking out chicks
acids as they would walk by.
That's where his mind was.
Um,
in Australia you do a,
in Australia,
like,
and I've done this like,
again,
like on domestic flights you can
take liquids on and I don't know,
I don't know what to do.
Like I was about to throw the
water away and the guy was like,
no,
bring it on is so raw.
And I'm like,
that's kind of weird man.
Some places they don't make
you take your sneakers off.
Yeah.
It's,
this is weird.
Different places,
different takes on it.
The whole thing's ridiculous.
Or like,
or like,
I'm sorry,
Atlanta when I,
when I,
I my my,
my wife was studying is southwest man.
She was studying more area,
which is like known to be like a drug,
uh,
like drug slash like,
you know,
um,
uh,
mafia,
all these like Russian mob.
Anyone who's doing some
illegal shit goes to Marbella.
And when I landed at the airport like,
you know how like usually there's like,
you know,
customs this and that.
There is no like you could just,
I was like,
I could have like a bag
filled with heroin right now.
And they were like,
come on in man.
So it's known for being like an illegal,
yeah,
if you go down there zone,
I'll tell you,
I,
I realized like I was
walking on the beach.
It's beautiful.
I was walking on the little
boardwalk and I saw this like big,
you know how Russian,
some Russian dudes are just like,
they're big.
This guy was big.
He had like the short
kind of short shorts,
no shirt on,
like black socks all the way
up to the knee on a cell phone,
just walking like with a gold chain.
I'm like that dude,
the Russian mob,
like,
come on man.
I was like Tony Soprano
going out for a walk.
You know
Russian mobs way scarier to
me than the Italian Mama.
Hell yeah.
Italian mom was so much ego and flashiness
and like all this shit that John
Gotti did.
You know everybody like
thought of John God.
He's like,
wow,
this is like the ultimate gangster.
No,
this is the ultimate thing
you're not supposed to do.
You're not supposed to like be on TV where
everybody knows who the fuck you are.
You're not supposed to like be so
blatant about it all when fucking $15,000
suits and having people knocked off
in front of steak houses like this is
ridiculous.
You guys are going to
ruin the whole thing.
And it did wind up
ruining the whole thing.
Whereas the Russian mobsters,
when was the last time a Russian
mobster got clipped was on TV.
There's no rush.
And John,
God,
he's there are,
but you're never going to
fucking hear about them.
Well,
the thing about the Russians too is like,
again,
I talk about this on stage
and it's total truth.
It's like they like if you watch any time,
like there's something going on,
like there's,
I would say like whenever
there's a hostage situation,
like these guys are so bad ass,
they shut with a military shows
up and they just kill everybody.
They're not,
they're like,
yeah,
we might save some,
we might say some hostages,
but they'll probably die.
We're going to kick
kill the hostage takers,
kill the hostage.
We might kill each other.
There's still bad ass.
And that's why I'm serious.
It's like the biggest mobsters and Russia.
It's like Vladimir Putin is like,
Ma these,
the leader,
he,
when he,
when he left his prime minister,
he made the night.
You'd made the other guy,
what's his name?
Um,
uh,
I got his name,
just slipped my mind right now.
But he brought,
the other guy is the president and
then he just became prime minister.
It's like when you pull shit like that,
it's like,
all right this dude,
it's gangster shit.
It's gangster shit.
And he's a med Memphian Judy.
Yeah in VF and he's a black belt in judo,
like a legit blackbelt still trains,
flips,
people do the fucking air.
So he like lets everybody like
Obama and like bitch I'll kill you.
And you see it in the eye.
It's like when you watch like what,
I'm sorry,
I again,
I saw the press conference is,
it was the contrast if
you can like youtube,
it maybe like there's a,
like after September 11th there's a press
conference with Bush and Putin and you
know like Bush was like with a speech,
you know with us or against the smoke
them out of the whole whole who who,
you know and Putin was
just straight up like,
what are you guys going to do?
He's like,
we're going to kill them.
Like who is like anyone wear turban,
we kill,
you know,
and it's like you see it in his eyes.
Like he's like,
he's thinking like,
okay,
I will say what I need to save,
but afterwards some
dying is going to happen.
Apparently,
you know,
Bush and Putin had a meeting and a Bush
was so offensively ignorant that Putin
like immediately started changing the
way he negotiates and deals with America
afterwards.
Like just didn't respect
what Bush had to say,
which was like giving him advice
about things and he's like,
[inaudible],
who the fuck are you talking to?
Man?
I'm flattered me or Putin pitch,
hey,
you're just a son of some fucking CIA
age is to be the puppet and charge.
Like,
I'm really running shit.
Russia.
That's the difference between
like the president of America,
the president of America is like some
sort of a fucking figurehead for giant
corporations.
The guy who's running Russia
is really running Russia.
Yeah,
absolutely man.
Pretty bad ass.
You know,
I always say like,
I don't fuck with Russia's man.
That's a tough,
tough up there,
man.
Yeah.
You know that fucking story.
Aw skull where fade or a million inco.
The former heavyweight
pride champion came from,
I never watched documentaries
on that kind of that life.
You know,
you'll like look at him up
there and that mining town,
you're saying shit freezing.
Fucking cold.
It's like hours away
from Saint Petersburg,
Russia by train the fuck are you
doing out some hardy ass people?
Yeah,
man.
That'll fuck around.
You know they have wolf problems up there.
I'll do that.
Yeah.
They're having giant packs of super
wolves that are banding together for the
first time and killing livestock
because it's so fucking cold.
It's winter.
It got so cold up there that many packs
of wolves joined together to become one
giant pack because they're,
they're the,
they're the freezing temperatures were
killing all of their game and they were
getting desperate.
So they form some sort of a new strategy
and we'd go into fucking towns and just
jack all their,
all their livestock who that's
gotta be the worst way to go.
Can you imagine if you like
walking home with a
girlfriend or you know,
wife after like dinner
one night and you're like,
oh that was great dinner and then you,
you look back,
you're like as a pack of fucking
wolves are terrifying to him.
Like,
cause we've killed them
off in this country.
And then we started restocking.
I'm like,
they're having a problem
right now in Idaho.
I believe it is because a,
they've stocked the uh,
the giant gray wolf from Canada and they
brought it into Idaho to try to like
bring,
bring the population's up.
But now the populations are out of the,
out of control and they're in like
the several thousands and then another
killing livestock and fucking things up.
And you have to worry about them with
people too because they're big animals
only 180 pounds and they will kill people.
Like all that big bad wolf shit and
Little Red Riding Hood Shit where it was
always wolves.
That's because wolves used to kill people.
Yeah,
yeah.
Before we figured out tanks
and jets and guns and you know,
there was like there was a real issue.
Yeah,
you don't want to fuck with a wolf man,
don't fuck with him.
That's why there,
there was a great documentary on
Yellowstone and the cycle of life and
Yellowstone and one of the things that
talked about is how the wolves got
stronger over the winter and all
these other animals got fucked.
All these other animals,
like they couldn't find their vegetation.
They had digging through all this snow
to get to their plants and the wolves
were just eating all these deer so they
would be well fed and they would be
stronger.
And the livestock,
the Caribou,
the deers,
they would all slowly start to the weekend
and they would all just get taken out
by wolves as fascinating to watch,
man.
Two thoughts came to mind.
One was,
I remember as a kid in Iran,
in Tehran,
I was,
I left when I was six and
I remember my dad was like,
my dad was,
was like a manly man.
Like,
he's just like,
you know,
like,
and he was and he was a self
made millionaire neuron.
So like he was like back then,
like he was like the Godfather,
like the shitty would do for people.
He was like the Godfather,
like straight up like don Corleone,
like come to him,
whatever you need done.
But he and all his friends
were like wrestlers and shit.
Like,
like tough dudes.
A lot of wrestlers out of
round rod are wrestlers.
Yeah.
And then my dad was a big drinker
because he was from northern,
northern Iran.
Tabriz was it near the border of Russia?
So vodka was like water,
like they would drink it all the time.
So I just have this memory of my dad.
We were coming home from a party,
he was obviously drunk,
he was us home and there was a pack of
wild dogs like down the block from where
we live.
And my dad was so crazy,
like,
like manly.
He pulled the car over and picked up a
couple of rocks and started chasing the
pack of dog.
I'm coming here,
I'm like,
what family?
And the guard is throwing rocks
at wild and I'm sitting there,
I'm sitting there as a kid going like,
Damn,
my dad is as bad as you know,
when you grow up you're like,
no man,
my dad was good the fuck.
But Iranians are famous for their,
for their physical conditioning.
There's like a lot of techniques that
they used from Iran that are still used
today,
like physical conditioning
and certain like a,
the shield cast and a couple of fitness
moves and the wrestlers from Iran where
are known like internationally for being
some of the toughest wrestlers in the
world,
especially when you consider that
Iran is not a very large country but
consistently produced his top 10 w
worldclass wrestlers like every year.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Wrestling is one of our
big sports there and it's,
and it's,
uh,
it was,
it's a huge thing like chic bitch.
I seek baby recognize he was a
legit wrestler at one point in time,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
There's wrestling and weightlifting.
Weightlifting too is another one.
Like Iranians always compete.
It's kind of weird.
It's to manly country.
Yeah.
Mainly countries.
But it's funny,
the other thought that came to mind with
the walls when you talk about the wars
is having a kid.
I'm sure you've seen it.
It's like,
it's funny how these these
children's books and like,
you know,
obviously you know,
big,
bad wolf,
but like once in a while there'll be like,
you know,
this such as like the cute little wolf
or the cute little like some animals that
like,
you know,
the hippo,
my,
my son loves hippos.
He was talking about like hippos
and no for the most deaths in,
but my son is like,
I,
you know,
HIPPA,
the HIPPA,
her and like they're so cute
and the polar bears is coke.
Oh yeah,
exactly.
Cola.
Yeah,
yeah.
Monsters.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Fucking evil.
Cons.
Yeah.
It's funny,
like you could do like a,
you could do like a spoof,
like a behind,
like a,
like a behind the scenes.
You know how like some actors that
are like so lovable end up being such
assholes.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Like the fucking does star baseball
player who tells a kid to go fuck himself
the fuck Mr. Yeah.
You're my hero.
Fucking,
you know I love hippo.
Fuck you fucking bite in your car.
Tires off.
Hilarious.
There's a great picture online of this
African guy running from a hippo and it's
a,
it's a funny picture and
a terrifying picture.
It's funny because the guy made it,
he survived.
He got away from the hippo.
But it's fucking terrifying
when you watching it man.
Cause this guy is running in which
essentially a gigantic wild pig.
It's what they are.
There are different kind of pig.
They're in the family of pigs.
Pigs are ruthless assholes,
you know.
And this giant wild pig is chasing this
guy down the street and it's fucking
terrifying.
Could you imagine a thought,
like one of my thoughts
at that point would be,
are they like,
are they supposed to run faster?
Learning to think about,
do you know what I'm saying?
Like have I ever heard of a news
piece about these guys here?
Like you know,
the only that keeps you safe
is that they can't run too far.
Cause they're so big,
they're so big in the Karen,
so much mass in.
A lot of times they spend,
they spend a lot of
their time in the water.
They could run,
but it's not their best move.
You've got to outdistance them,
but this guy was running fast.
This thing looked like it
was like right on his ass.
One of the beautiful things about this
podcast is that we have this message
board@joerogan.net and whenever we bring
up something like this in the podcast,
there's a thread that's already dedicated
to the Mazda Bonnie podcasts that
hilarious.
What is his name?
Mr Dennison.
He puts it up.
I should give the guy credit
because he puts it up.
Yes,
Mr Dennison.
Cool motherfucker.
He's always doing this,
but I know somewhere on this
thread someone's going to
put that picture of that
hippo chasing.
That guy is a beautiful thing.
The Internet's a beautiful
thing in that respect.
Yeah.
You know,
you said that picture that Tom,
when African stuff,
have you seen those pictures?
I think it was,
might've been Mogadishu.
Have you seen those pictures are like
the of these guys when they were chasing
dudes with machetes.
Did you remember that shit?
There was like something
going on I think in the,
I think it was Mogadishu years ago.
It might've been.
That might've been there.
Yeah,
that would be a Rwanda then.
that's the Tutsis and Hutus or what?
However you say hotel Rwanda.
But it's crazy to see human
beings chasing each other.
The dude was like straight up chasing.
They were chasing this one dude.
They had machetes in their
hands and you sit first,
first thought is like,
Holy Shit.
Second thought is this camera man is not,
he's sitting there going like
picture of this.
You know?
I'd be like,
okay,
I could tell the story.
I'm not going to plug in.
And then the third thing is
just that poor guy's like,
he's going to get,
they're going to catch
him and they're going,
if I can chop them to pieces.
Yeah,
that is crazy.
Human beings are such assholes.
Well,
especially in Africa,
man,
there's a long history of that should go
on down in Africa and the w whatever we
were talking about,
the Hutus and the tts.
However you say it.
Somebody correct me to
please somebody on Twitter.
Correct me.
Those guys,
you know,
like one of the things about
the horrors of that war is it,
they would go into a town and kill
thousands of people with machetes.
Yeah.
Just chop them up and then they would
pollute the river because they were throw
so many bodies in the river,
but the water from the river road become
undrinkable because it was rotten with
human bodies.
Yeah.
It's a fucking,
it's a terrifying place in
Africa is so fucking wild.
It's so fucking it to this day in 2011
it's probably the wildest place on Earth,
but just Warren
general,
like they were talking about,
they just caught one of these other,
uh,
Serbs,
Serbian leaders,
the,
remember there's Milosevic.
And then there was another
guy that he's just caught,
I forget his name,
but there,
but they've got all these counts
of a human atrocities against him.
He was a general,
I guess.
And he would go into town and they would
capture the enemies and then they would
say,
he was just,
I'm like,
you know,
hey,
it's all good.
We just wanted to capture
the town so all the men,
you guys can come out
and we'll let you go.
And like the men will come
out and they would mass.
He would,
they would get them out by
like saying like it's all good.
And once they come out,
like they would massacre
the men and then they go,
they raped the women.
I mean it's just like,
why do you got to do it?
You know what I'm saying?
And it old school Gingiss con type Shit.
Oh my God.
People that are just,
Oh,
the Hutus
and the Tutsis and Hutus.
Great Movie Hotel Rwanda by the way.
Thank you.
Create culture and Perry for one one and
Frederick Lambert and read three read.
Shout out to my brother in law.
He loves to show PD PD money.
I don't know if he's listening right now.
Are Not bloody money.
What's happening brother?
PD money.
He loves to show him
and he loves your show.
I was in Vancouver and we came
out of this a steak restaurant.
I was a bad Bobby and a savage signs from
the Rogan board and we stepped out of
this steak restaurant
and as we stepped out,
the guy goes,
hey,
and he puts his hand on my shoulder and
then he pulls off his ear buds and shows
me his iPod and he's
listening to the podcast.
That's awesome.
How cool is it was it was ridiculous.
I was like,
wow,
that is fucking nuts,
man.
That's a surreal moment,
right?
So surreal.
It's like I heard sting in an interview.
He said he knew he was starting to make
it when he was at some meeting in some
office in the high rise,
and he's,
I don't know if this is true or not.
He said he saw the guy outside clean
the window and the guy was like singing
Roxanne or some.
He was like,
Oh shit.
I made it.
Well,
once Eddie Murphy Sang that in that movie,
Oh my God.
It just became,
I didn't even know about that song until
I saw that movie and Eddie Murphy was
singing it in the movie.
Yeah
Dude,
as a kid that might have been one of my
favorite movie moment cause I went into
that movie being a huge Eddie Murphy Fan.
How could you not?
And then when they introduce
them like that you like he,
he just,
he basically lived up to everything you
expected and then that movies has got
better.
I watched that movie now like you
know when he goes into the bar,
you know,
you best have yourself a black Russian,
like there's a new sheriff,
their name is Reggie Hammond.
Oh man,
it's so great man.
Dude,
he was the best.
No one was a better comedic actor in a
movie than Eddie Murphy in my opinion.
48 hours.
[inaudible] Nick Naulty,
he just took off and it was
the right amount of vulnerable,
the right amount of bad ass and cocky
and the right amount of self deprecating.
And he was like 22 at that point.
It's ridiculous.
And a killer stand up.
Oh my God.
It's almost a shame that he had all this
problems with trannies and what have
you.
He doesn't want to go on stage.
He doesn't want people to heckle him
because God damn at one point in time,
if you go back and listen to his shit,
when he was 19 he was a brilliant
comedian and like 19 years old.
Yeah,
it was very funny actually.
I rented some like old videos and
there was a comment like a national
competition and they were,
they showed the top five winners and he
was fifth place and everyone had heard
of them.
Then on it,
they're not allowed to know anyway.
It's gone.
Well he doesn't even do comedy anymore.
That's the weird thing his brother does.
You know,
it's like Charlie's out there
carrying on the family name.
It's funny because when people ask
me about how I got into comedy,
I was in college and I'd like,
I thought about doing it a few times and
I was always intimidated because I had
done acting in plays,
but I was on,
I wasn't limited to get in front of an
audience and talk about like my point of
view.
It was that,
you know,
so I was in college and I saw these
two guys and there was just horrible.
It was a comedy competition.
And so I told myself the next time
there's a competition I'm just going to do
it.
So I was telling people,
I say,
you know,
you get inspired by
greatness and mediocrity.
I was inspired by mediocrity.
And the funny thing is I,
I'm just like maybe a year,
year and a half ago,
I'm at the comedy store and the
original room on a Tuesday and I,
and I just came off like this big tour
in Australia where I was like headline in
front of a lot of people and you know,
it was like automatic.
I called on a Monday,
just gave avails for every night.
And so I get a Tuesday night show.
So I go off and it's like
the crowds not that great.
I'm not into it.
I'm like,
I just,
I've just got to get off the road doing,
you know,
thousand people in like an hour 20
and now I've got to do 15 minutes.
I don't want to try anything new.
I was like,
I don't even want to be here.
why don't I do this?
I get on stage,
I'm just all over the place.
Nothing's really hidden.
The only person laughing is Johnny's Zap.
You Know Jack is a,
yeah sure.
And what's funny about Johnny's APP
is in the past when I first became a
regular,
the comedy store,
Johnny's App,
actually I'd like given me like he
lost a set one time and like he started
giving me tags and I didn't know
who he was cause he'll tell you,
he's like,
I was around when Richard Pryor was here,
this and that.
So I thought he was
like a genius of comedy.
Yeah.
So he gave me like some tags and
quickly I realized it was like no this,
this is a dude who hangs
out and it was crazy.
Crazy do the hangs out like you know,
cause then he started give me the
table like these are horrible.
So I'm sitting on stage,
I'm kind of dying and Zap as the only one
laughing and I'm like thank you Johnny
and a and then I'm getting ready to get
off stage and Steve Burns the next comic
and Steve always like does like a
long kind of jokey intro for me.
Like whenever the WHO's next Mazda
Bronnie I don't know who that is.
Well whatever this next guy,
I'm not sure if guys want to
watch him and he'll do like that.
So I started doing that to Steve and I'm
just riffing a little bit and it's just
getting like this is a very mediocre set.
I'm walking off stage,
zap waves me down,
it's a Tuesday night and I'm like,
Oh God zaps got a tag for me.
And he goes,
hey man,
Eddie Murphy's here.
And I thought he was in the main room
cause Eddie Murphy is always in the main
room,
right?
So I thought he was like,
oh,
I didn't know if it in the mirror.
I was like,
so what?
So I start walking and as I walk in,
Eddie was,
Eddie was sitting the whole set
watching my set in Mitzi seat,
you know Mitzi seat.
I walked past Eddie.
I'm like,
oh my God,
I just died in front of my comedy.
I walked down the steps,
turn around waiting for my
buddy who's coming to get me.
We're going to go to the laugh factory.
Eddie walks down in front of my buddy.
It gives me the quick little look.
Doesn't say anything,
just keep walking.
Oh.
So in the back of my mind,
the only saving graces,
I'm thinking to myself,
okay,
he's going to make a comeback,
is going to end up on the tonight show.
I think I'd be like,
what inspired you to come back?
And He'd be like,
you know,
I was watching this mediocre set one time.
The reason he came back,
you brought it anywhere.
If he backs
how I roll man,
that's Volaris.
So no,
I was talking about this on the Kevin
Smith show about going on stage and you
know how some guys will
just go on stage fearlessly.
Like Chris Rock would go
onstage fearlessly with a
batch of new material and
just hash it out and see
what the fuck happens.
And if it,
if it comes out it comes out.
But it's,
it's so tough to bomb.
There's a bomb in front of a guy like
Eddie Murphy must be just fucking
terrible.
I was just the mean because,
oh and here's the funny thing
was halfway through the set,
I'm not kidding,
was a Tuesday night as I was kind of like,
cause the whole time I'm going just get
it together and get through it and Ma
and be funny and pat and pardon me,
he's like,
I'm all over the place.
So my head's really not into
it and I'm not even like,
cause sometimes I go up there and just go,
I'm going to riff for five
minutes for new material.
I just wasn't,
you know,
the year up there I'm like,
why do I even put in so halfway
through the set I'm like,
dude,
get your shit together and make it a
good set cause somebody might be in the
audience.
And I swear to God that the
past 12 years I've been there,
I have never had that thought.
And I thought to myself,
and then the,
the,
the other voice,
the comedy store voice came in my head.
I was like,
who the fuck is going to be in the side?
Like,
you know,
and who cares?
Like the whole point of the comedy
store is to go with who cares?
Like,
you know,
and so it was one of those like who cares,
who's cool give in this audience that
has any kind of influence of agent or
something.
It's fucking Eddie Murphy.
So don't realize when you
talk about the comedy store,
you know,
that's like one of like I used
to say when I lived in Boston,
that was Mecca.
Yeah.
I would hear about like
Kennison and Richard Pryor
and that was the comedy store
in Hollywood.
But then you actually get
there and you realize,
Oh,
this is an insane asylum
and no one's watching it.
No one's paying any attention.
And then fucking Mike is just turned
on at one point in the night and then
there's no host.
Even now,
convenience tag team.
What's this?
No Club in town that does that,
by the way.
All the comedians just
bring each other up.
No,
there's a fucking host,
like a professional show and the guy
will go up and I'll bring people up and
I'll do a little time in between and
the give you your intro and get it
straight.
This is not a fucking get your
intro straight at the store.
Yeah,
no,
not at all.
[inaudible] I'll be honest,
cause that's where I
actually grew as a cop.
Like I,
I'd done one year comedy.
Then it became,
it became a regular coffee store and it
was great because there was no pressure.
It was like you're going to,
I got used to shit crowds.
That was what was weird when I started
performing the laugh factory and there's
real crowds and I was like,
oh my God,
God you're so nice at
the Improv with the fuck.
It's so weird.
And it's weird seeing guys who started
in town and started at one of the clubs
with audiences.
I actually saw a couple of comic comics
one time I saw this at the laugh factory
one comic go like oh I'm
not going after songs.
So,
and I was like,
oh that's an option.
I didn't realize I an option at the store.
I mean how many times did Mitzi
shove you on after some killer,
some Martin Lawrence type character.
Someone would go up and destroy ego,
Mars
and also,
and also what happened?
Like the weirdest one I had was one
time it was one of these thin nights,
not all night,
not much of an audience.
Dice does a stop in,
he's going to do like an hour and the
crowd in is this a thin crowd but it's his
crowd.
They start loving him and
I'm trying to like work on,
it was like,
like kinda towards like,
like the Iraq war and I'm trying to work
on some like war antiwar ship political
shit.
And he's doing like,
you know,
fuck ass and fuck this fucking name
it,
doing it,
and they're loving them.
And then it was weird.
He does one joke and somehow there was
feedback on the mic and he just looks at
the mic for a second.
They looks at the audience,
he drops the mic and he walks off
and the,
and the piano is not there.
There's no one there,
no one,
like you said,
no one is running the asylum
and nobody even said like,
who's next?
It's just dead.
And the artist is kind of like,
that's weird.
And no one's there.
So I'm like,
I'm next.
I got to go up.
So I had to go up on stage and be like,
hey,
how are you guys doing?
I'm Mazda Ronnie.
Nobody knew who the fuck I was.
You know that that just makes you tough.
You learn,
you know what I'm saying?
My hardest sats were fallen
dice at a bunch of hearts sets,
fallen dice.
How fallen dice fallen.
Martin Lawrence,
fallen men steelier following fall.
Richard Pryor when Richard
Pryor was still doing stand up.
Shit.
Yeah,
those were,
those were weird times,
but Mitzi was always
real smart about that.
If she thought you were any good,
she wasn't going to give you an easy spot.
If she thought you were
decent and you had a,
you know,
a spark in you should throw you
on in the worst position possible.
What is it?
A black show?
Yeah.
Pulling them on after Amar and Laurie
and she would think it's
funny knowing that you get,
I think that would be fun.
I think that would be like,
like the best challenges that have just
being able to try that or it is what?
After it's over.
Yeah.
Well here's the thing.
Sometimes sometimes it works well if
you go in there with like I'm fucked
mentality.
Yeah.
If you ride the wave though,
one time I did one time they were,
they were doing something
in the main room.
It was like a,
it was the black film festival and they
had a comedy show and was supposed to be
headlined by Eddie Griffin.
So people had to actually come expecting
Eddie and Eddie walked in and saw that
they'd sold tickets and he's like,
I'm not getting paid or some shit.
He got upset about something.
He's like,
I'm not going up.
So then so then someone
came to me and they're like,
hey we need you to get in there,
the close out the show.
So they're expecting to Eddie Griffin
and I walk up and it was so funny cause
they just,
everyone just got up and started walking
out and like there was like one table
that hung out and literally like I was
so like defeat at the top that I just,
I was like,
thanks for hanging out.
I said,
I feel like I'm,
I'm,
I'm the,
I'm the rolling credits
at the end of the film.
I said that's what it feels
like for the film fest.
If it was just leaving and that one
table was with me because it was all safe
self deprecating material
because it was like,
you know,
what am I doing here?
And it was like 15,
20 minutes of that.
And you live sometimes though,
if you go into that situation where
it's still kind of a hot crowd and,
and then you go in and now you got to
perform in f and it's like they get,
you know,
they're not laughing and,
and then you try some crowd
work and it's not working.
I had that on a Mo Betta
Mondays if the Improv one time.
And it was funny cause
I'd gotten good cause I,
cause I did,
um,
I did Friday after next,
so I had some street credit in the black,
black,
black community,
the [inaudible] and uh,
and s as a holy moly donut shop.
You know,
this,
this character in the movie.
So I'd been doing,
you know,
I did chocolate Sundays,
I did that with copy store one and then
I overheard a few people talking about
how Mo Betta Mondays was one
of the toughest black rooms.
I was like,
how tough could it be and
I'm getting ready to go on.
And this one other comic was like,
Hey man,
you got your shit together
to in Tripoli was there too.
He's like listen bro,
just hang in there to Dah Dah Dah Dah.
And I went up and I ate so much shit
cause it was this like it was a crowd
because you go in there,
it was early in the show and you
expect it to be a good crowd.
And it's one of those things where you
get like a couple of laughs and like you
hear the pin drop kind of thing and then
you try another joke is not working.
Then you try some crowd work and is not
working and then you start going against
your own instincts or your instincts
like okay attack that attack the CIC
wearing the pink,
you know,
whatever the whatever the pink
fucking antennas for whatever,
you know,
attack,
attack the dude in the
purple leather suit.
You know,
it's just funny.
But then,
but then you're like,
no,
they're going to kick your ass.
And then he's just going to like,
give me that light,
man.
Let me get ready to pick on
someone when you're bombing.
Oh my God.
It's really,
you don't feel confident to pick out,
so yeah.
Oh,
it's the worst
bombing and a black crowd is a,
is really hard too because it's
very hard to pull yourself out.
Oh yeah.
Once it goes down,
white crowds will give you some room
and Albert Black crowds like next.
Yeah.
Kay has a great story about bombing on
Mo Betta Mondays that he went up and he
goes,
he realized that there was no recovering.
Like they w they didn't
want you to recover.
You know,
like he,
he tried out a joke and it wasn't,
it didn't work and that was it.
They were like,
next,
get off.
You're like,
wait a minute.
I could try some other shit.
Nope.
Get outta here.
Come on guys.
Yeah,
it's uh,
it's,
you know,
I think it's also,
it's good to do like a room like
that where people don't have any,
the,
you know,
they have no problem with Boone.
You off the stage real quick.
Oh,
it's not the best thing
to do all the time,
but every now and then it's
good as a little reality check.
You Shit better be tight son,
but it come out that gate swinging.
Yeah.
And the most important thing is what?
The first bit that first
bit gotta be strong.
Oh hell yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh you want to open with
your closer if it's possible,
if you don't need to set that bitch
up with your personality beforehand.
Yeah,
you're right.
Right.
Yeah.
But the other good thing that
you learned when you do that,
cause I remember learning this early on,
I was like never believed the height
because there's sometimes some nights
you'll kill and you're like I am God and
then some nice you die and like you'd
like depressed.
I was like,
you can never go with like the,
the good thing about these lessons
on those things is to go listen man,
my Shit's funny.
They didn't work tonight.
But that's a funny joke.
That's a funny joke.
I've had sets before where,
and usually it happens in the comic store,
original room.
Where's not like an all black crowd.
It's like this crowd of crowd of like,
you know,
few Norwegians,
couple Ozzie's,
couple of La hipsters.
It's just,
it's all this like mixed crowd and I'm
having a blast and they're not laughing.
And I've seen comedians like be like,
you know,
you guys don't get it,
but I don't even go to the,
you don't get it.
I just go like guys,
that was a,
that was a funny,
like,
I'm Kinda like,
you guys won't be on the ride.
That's fine.
I think that was funny.
You know,
and I,
I know I'm funny,
so fuck you guys.
And I got another eight
minutes and I'm done.
You know.
Well,
you know,
the problem with comedy I've always
said is that it's just called comedy and
it's not like you never go to a club to
see live music and it says live music
and you don't know if you're going to
get a rap band or if you're going to get
fucking guns and roses or classical music.
It's very clear.
You know what you're going to go to
when you go to a blues club again to get
some blues.
But when you go to a comedy club,
man,
you can get anything.
Yeah.
How you could get by as Giovanni,
you could get Dang cooked,
you could get this guy,
you get that guy,
everyone's got a different taste.
And some people might love
Judas Freelander and some
people might hate him and
love Tracy Morgan.
And so,
you know,
it's like,
it's all so subjective.
Yeah.
That's got to find your audience.
And one of the beautiful things about
showing up places where it's not your
audience to showing up
on some random night at,
uh,
at the Improv is that
you can't stack the deck.
So you have to make some people
laugh that don't even fucking know.
You don't know know your shit.
So I'm sure now you must get these
huge crowds of people who know Mazda,
Ronnie.
So they come out to see you.
You know?
But I think every now and then
you got to go in front of,
I love actually I love,
like I always say like,
I don't like to be in front
of everyone that knows me.
One reason is you feel like,
okay,
they might have heard a lot of this shit
even if it's new now with the Internet
it's gone.
Yep.
Um,
and secondly,
I love,
I just love like,
like for example,
one thing that happens with my audience
is like what happened was when we first
did the ACCC evil comedy tour came out
on comedy central and a lot of young like
middle easterners started following us.
But then they started bringing their
parents and growing up like in the Middle
Eastern community,
like it's like,
you know,
you're very like your,
you don't go to blue.
Like,
you know,
you gotta be nice and polite.
I mean,
you could get,
you know,
get a little edgy,
but you don't cuss.
You know,
like there's a whole thing like for the
longest time with my mom and my like I
was just,
it was a still to me.
Don't cost,
definitely not around,
you know,
Persians,
you're not going to cost.
How much do you cuss on stage ever?
I don't cuss much.
I cuss a little bit,
but I actually,
what's funny is I like now what I do is
if I make a reference to something like,
like there's a joke I do where
I mentioned masturbation,
I actually make fun of that.
That's why I love having a mixed audience.
Cause I'll look,
I'll look at the white
guy in the audience.
I go now,
Hey Mike,
right now there's a table
of Persian is going,
oh my God,
he said masturbation.
You know,
I brought my mother,
she doesn't speak English.
Now I have to travel.
It must've Bishan at the Farsi.
So riff on what thinking.
And inevitably there's always like this
one table that's dying of laughter.
And I've had people come
up after the show be like,
dude,
I was here with my mom when
you were saying that shit.
It was totally true.
And the mother's totally cool with it.
I was just,
I had this recently,
um,
it,
uh,
at the Tampa Improv I was doing it and
there was literally this old very like
distinguished sweet older lady that
was the mother of this other lady.
So the other lady was like my mom's age.
The other,
the,
the mother was like my grandmother's
age and I said masturbation.
I did the riff.
And the funny part of the whole
thing was as I was doing the riff,
the mother was leaning into
the grandmother translating
everything and I was
like,
Holy Shit is actually
happening in the crowd.
Loved it.
Cause I was making fun of it
but it was actually happening.
Oh that's funny.
Yeah.
That's funny.
Where,
where do you like performing the best?
God I love,
I mean,
I mean I still love the original
room just for creativity purposes,
you know?
Um,
um,
and then,
and then what did with
that Tuesday night thing?
I mean I guess,
look,
we all love killing in front of
our audience is like whenever like,
like some of the cities I love
like is one of my favorite cities.
First of all,
one of the things I love about DC,
it's very international.
Secondly everyone in DC is doing shit.
Like whenever I spent a couple of
days in DC you meet people like,
Hey,
where do you work?
Is like I work at state.
Oh what's the State Department?
Oh okay,
cool.
What do you do?
I look at the agency agency.
Cia Let people actually like doing and
I would say like when I went there that
was Kinda,
it was good.
The trip.
I would hate that it,
no it's dance for the CIA.
No Dude,
it's the craziest thing cause
like I would say like I,
I was there recently,
I was like,
what's great about you guys is like,
like if I'm in la I'll be like,
what are you doing?
They'll be like,
oh,
I'm working on a movie
about a spy who goes to,
you know,
to,
to South America to
overthrow the government.
I go when you come to DC though,
what are you doing?
He's like,
I'm a spy who was going to go to
South America over though and I love,
but it's just you feel like you're in
the heart of like you meet people that
mean like are doing shit.
I remember one time being
that actually I had a moment,
I remember I was,
I was there,
it was right at the time of like right
in the heart of the Bush administration
and remember uh,
um,
homeland security.
Tom Ridge,
remember him,
he was the first guy and you see
them on TV and he's a talking head.
He's an older dude.
I was outside this like fancy restaurant
in DC and he's sitting there talking to
this like attractive young girl,
kind of like you could tell his
body language was all flirty,
you know?
And he's a big dude too.
And I was like,
this guy's just trying to
get pussy like everyone else.
I was like,
he's the head of homeland security.
He probably be like,
Hey,
you want me to,
you want,
you want to see the terror alert.
Go to Orange County,
maybe you want to see the red button.
That's hilarious.
But you see those kinds of guys when
you're out there as opposed to la as
opposed to like anywhere.
I mean you don't,
you don't see that.
Let you know to live out here still is.
You do it.
You're doing most of
your work is on the road,
right?
Yeah.
Most of my words on the road,
I mean I live,
listen La,
I love la in that my family's here.
A lot of my friends are
here and weather wise,
you know how it is when you
travel around the world,
you come back like I was in Norway
and it's like negative land.
They're like negative three
with windshield windshield.
It's like w windshield factor.
It's you know,
negative 15 or even Chicago,
which is a great city.
But in December it's a mother fucker.
I'm like,
what is wrong with you people,
you know?
And the beauty of La,
I always say the great thing
about La is it's so close to such,
so many great.
But I grew up in the bay area,
so I love going up to the bay.
You go to Santa Barbara,
you go to Vegas,
you go to s,
you know San Diego,
everything's close by.
Yeah.
La is an amazing city.
It's just overpopulated.
Oh yeah.
If,
if we didn't live in la though,
it probably so much more enticing.
I would say that like
when I'm driving around,
God,
if I wasn't a live here,
I probably appreciate this more.
I'd probably like,
wow,
what an incredible place
I should live in La.
There's,
there's a,
a great amount of shitheads in this city,
but it's just because the numbers,
the numbers are so high.
But I mean the,
you know,
what is funny?
Like,
like whenever I go to New York,
I love New York in terms of like,
it's like a playground for adults.
Like you just jumped in a cab
to go to the next restaurant,
you go to the next club,
you go to,
what are you going all night?
You want to live there?
I would want to know.
Well I actually,
I'd always thought I wanted to live there
and then I did two projects out there
where I was there for four months at a and
it was like I got an apartment at the
corner of Houseton six which is like the
heart of the village.
I was like,
this is the best place dude from
7:00 AM till 3:00 AM every day.
It was like noise outside.
It was just so like cars punking and and,
and construction.
And I was like,
you know,
New York I think is good.
If you're in your 20s and you got your
buddies and you're all making some money
and you just want to run around,
like I guess the ratio of
women to men is like this.
Like I don't,
I don't know,
it's like 55 to 45 or so.
A lot more women than men.
And there's a lot of models
walking around New York.
How about you?
So if I had like beaucoup
Howard stern type co cashflow,
I would be into live in,
in,
in New England.
I did Manhattan like with some sort of
a apartment that overlooks like central
park or something like that.
If you've got like Madonna money,
get some one of those crazy $20 million
apartments because I've seen some
online,
some people put some up on
my message board as well.
And they,
there was a one that had
like a corner building.
It was a corner,
a apartment with insane views of the city.
That's some of the most beautiful things
when you look at like a real city scape
and it's lit at night.
Oh yeah,
I see.
What a fucking amazing,
I just think that the numbers of people,
when you're in a place like Manhattan,
the,
all the influence they have over you,
all the people around you all the time.
I just don't think you
can have real piece there.
I don't think you can relax.
Well that's what's crazy
is when I was living there,
uh,
and those stance,
like I remember coming home
one weekend and I lent,
we have a house here and I remember
hearing a bird chirping outside.
I was like,
I have not heard a bird chirp except
for your was he's got a bird chirping.
He's got the alarms or noise of the
bird chirp or that the chirps different
different noises.
No,
but New York is New York is great to
visit and party and stuff and even the way
it goes back to the weather,
it's like I had the craziest
experiences in New York where I'm like,
oh,
it's a sunny day.
I walk into a meeting,
I walk out and it's pouring rain.
I'm like,
what the hell happened?
And it's hot and humid.
That's most of the world.
Most of the world has
to deal with weather.
Yeah.
I have to deal with whether we just have
to deal with the once a decade or two,
the way the world moves
and shit falls down.
They just sold the father
of the bride house.
I'm going to remember the
movie father of the bride,
but does this huge,
really nice house.
He was in that movie,
Steve Martin,
you know,
and he was like the father
of the bride and uh,
Rick Moran is,
I think it might've been
in or something like that,
but I just saw that house for sale on
some website the other day for say.
And I was like,
that would be the most ideal house in
California cause it was actually picked
for the movie because of how
wholesome in Nice it looked.
Where was it?
Where was it was in Malibu.
Where was gonna say was like
in my Pasadena or something.
We are still,
we're Martin short plays like a
gay wedding direct gay wedding.
Yeah,
like a German gay wedding.
He's actually very funny.
When I was leaving,
uh,
Kevin Smith's place today,
I did his podcast this morning
and when I was leaving this place,
they had one of those
tours where there's a,
like a bus that doesn't have a top to it.
People were out in the open air and there
there is a star sightings and they're
driving through the Hollywood
hills pointing out celebrities houses.
I got fucked.
Is that,
that is when you show
people while you sleep.
That's weird.
In general.
Like,
I don't know,
like I've,
I've done a few tours in my life.
Like what?
Even if it's like at a,
at a,
like a museum,
I guess.
So bored so fast.
I'm like,
I don't need to spend an hour for you
to tell me about this painting and the
painter and the,
I just read five minute,
move on,
much less sit in the
fucking van and be like,
Oh,
Kevin Smith.
Luke also lives here.
I'm like,
get me off this fucking
bus for some people,
man.
Meeting celebrities is very important.
It's,
we're excited about it.
It's weird.
Yeah.
You must be fucking huge
in the Persian community.
Well that's what,
well,
it's weird.
I like,
you know,
in terms of,
yeah,
I mean the,
the Persian community like
knows me as a celebrity.
It's actually funny.
I just,
I was just in,
um,
I was at a lax,
uh,
two days ago and had all these like
flight problems and we're running around
from southwest trying to get to
American Airlines and coming back.
And then I,
you know,
I got the Google alerts,
so like it sends me like if,
if you ever get mentioned in
something like a sends you.
So I was just like,
I got the Google alert and it
was like celebrity spotting.
It was like,
Huh.
And I look it up and it's so funny,
somebody was like,
Mazda Bronnie spotted at the,
at lax.
And what was even funnier though is like,
it's like,
you know,
like Justin Bieber has like
10,000 celebrity spottings like,
you know,
so I got to celebrities like,
Hey,
I'm working my way slowly Persians,
that person.
Actually,
you know what's funny,
this happened to,
this was the weird one,
one time,
um,
uh,
Aaron cater and I had just done
a gig and Jordan of all places,
whoa.
And we flew back and we could,
is that like,
it was actually really cool
with the first time we,
the first time we ever did
Jordan was again with me.
I'm at an error and we went into the
ACCC evil comedy tour out in the Middle
East would have five countries.
We'd like 27 shows,
30 days,
all sold out.
It was like his big fish in a small pond.
You know what I'm saying?
Are you allowed to talk
about anything you,
well,
some countries like,
uh,
like Lebanon,
they go talk about whatever you
want because the Lebanese they have,
they've had the very liberal,
they're very bay route.
First of all is one of the most
amazing cities in the world.
We're going to check it out.
It's amazing.
It's like the nightlife is crazy.
There's like no rules or regulations.
Um,
the women are all beautiful.
the,
uh,
the food is delicious.
Uh,
and then,
and then you've got like that bizarre,
you can go check out the
bizarre kind of thing,
you know,
and then you could go
out into the mountains.
I mean,
it's just amazing.
I've had great time.
Every time I've kind of Beirut
and you could swear on stage,
swear to whatever you want.
Oh yeah.
Now,
so that's bay route.
Then you've got the other countries where
a lot of times the promoters will say,
no sex,
no religion,
no politics.
Oh yeah.
You're like,
well,
now stock,
you know,
said that right before you go onstage.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
Well the funny thing is
when they say no policies,
that means no local politics.
And thank God I don't know much about
the local politics and I'm not about to
challenge,
you know,
the shape of Dubai with some,
stupid shit.
So I lay,
you know,
the,
you're allowed to make fun of America.
You make fun of America.
I can make fun of Iran.
I used to make fun of the president,
Iran.
They loved it.
They,
if you make fun of their
neighboring country,
they're like,
that is hilarious.
They love that.
How close is the government
of Iran to being overthrown?
It's,
that's a tough call,
man.
It's,
it's interesting because there's like,
Eh,
I mean,
I,
I love politics anyway,
so I read up on it a lot,
you know,
and,
and there's so many different analysts
and it's like what it is is in Iran right
now it's over 75,
maybe 80 million people.
And there's a lot of young people like,
uh,
like a majority of young.
Yeah,
they have the Internet and
they want a modern way of life.
Well,
but the problem is,
and somebody pointed this out,
they were saying when the Iranian
revolution happened under the Shah,
a lot of the people that were
in [inaudible] leadership
position under the Shah
had been western educated.
And this guy made a good point.
He goes,
so when the revolution happened,
they had the money and they're like,
screw it,
we're outta here.
They went to France,
they went to London,
they came to America,
live their life.
They're all good.
The people that are running the
country now are not western educated.
They've been part of this revolution,
you know,
79 and they,
they,
you know,
so they got nowhere to go.
And when the,
when the ayatollah took over,
that was all us backed.
Right?
Like there was an issue with
the Shah when the United States,
was that a disagreement with the Shah.
So they backed the ayatollah
and got him conspiracy
theories and the sort.
But I think,
I mean a big part of it,
you could go back and trace it
to actually a movement happening.
That was an internal movement
because what happened was the Shah,
okay.
The Shaw Westernize the country a lot,
um,
and,
and had a lot of progress for the country.
Uh,
nonetheless,
under the Shah,
like as under any dictator in,
in the Middle East,
there was still a lot of
people being persecuted.
Like opposition was not looked,
you know,
it was frowned upon and you
would have like these like,
and you had different parties,
you had like hit the monarchists,
then you had like the nationalists,
then you had the socialists and
the communists and you had the,
you know,
the religious,
the Islamicists.
So you had all these different parties
and anytime anyone would say anything or
criticize the Shah,
like some dude would disappear.
You know,
they had,
yeah,
there was the Savak,
which was the secret police.
So there's all kinds of like intellectuals
that would like criticize them and
disappear.
Um,
and so there was,
there was that going on.
And so eventually what happened,
like the Khomeini's history goes
that he was actually exiled.
I lucky I said that by the way,
was the homie Romania,
Romania.
Yeah.
I'm trying to get my son to learn Farsi.
It's the funniest thing.
Seen this kid.
He's got like an American
accent already and he's like,
yeah,
he's three.
He'll be like,
come on,
are,
you know,
he fucks it up.
Anyway,
so he,
um,
Khomeini had been exiled to Iraq,
and uh,
and he was getting back then it was
kinda like the Twitter of today.
He was,
he would sneak,
he would sneak his sermons back
into Iran with tape cassettes.
So all these other religious guys,
there was a,
there's a,
there's a city named comb,
which is a religious city in Iran.
They were all getting like his sermons
and he was criticizing the Shah from
outside of Iran.
You can do that from outside,
but you can't do it from
inside Susan from outside.
And basically what happened was there was
all these different oppositions to the
Shah and discontent was growing
and protests were growing.
And so these guys all
kind of banded together.
And what they do is,
it's very similar to the protests that
were happening during the green movement
of 2009 where people would
be out protesting and then,
and then,
uh,
the government was shooting to
the crowds and kill some people.
And in the,
in the Muslim Shiite religion,
like once someone's killed like something
like seven days after some of these
like a morning day,
like,
so they all go out and they mourn.
So these guys would be morning and the,
and the Shah's police would show up and
shoot some more and it just grew and
grew and grew.
So the protests were originally like,
you know,
one faction,
but then it became more
factions and then you,
then you got to a point where you had
like lawyers and doctors protesting in the
streets of Iran,
like people that should
be supporting the regime.
And then you had the Bazaaris,
they run the,
the bazaar is like the,
the economy.
These guys shut down the economy,
the oil company went on strike.
So all this shit came together and then,
and then it costs with
the revolution to happen.
And I have a friend of mine
who was young back then.
He said what was interesting,
he goes like when the Shah left,
he goes,
for the first few days in Iran,
it was total euphoria
cause everyone was like,
we got rid of America,
we got rid of the this influence.
And he goes,
what was weird though was
cause cause for the protests,
all these factions were working together.
He goes now,
like one guy would be like,
hey,
we did it brother.
And the other guy would be like,
yeah,
we did do it.
Comrade.
He'd be like,
wait a minute brother,
he's a Muslim,
Islam is Conrad.
I'm a communist.
And then they would start turning on
each other and then the shift start
attorney and then,
and then the Islam is took over
and now we're in the shit we're in.
But all that stuff,
by the way,
in a,
in a lot of people have talked about this,
a lot of this stuff did happen.
Uh,
like in 53,
there was a democratically
elected government,
uh,
the,
the guy was named Mosad debt.
And the US,
actually,
the CIA has written their story of
how they did a coup d'etat of the
democratically elected leader in Iran.
They overthrew him and put the Shah in.
And so like whenever any American,
like whenever we talk about
wars and stuff and they're like,
we're just trying to bring democracy.
I'm like,
motherfucker,
they was democracy and we overthrew it.
You've got to read your history.
You know,
it's a fascinating time that we live in
when people talk about going to war with
Iran too,
you know,
when they're talking about disarming them,
if they continue with
their nuclear program.
Oh yeah.
Oh yes.
Strange Times,
you know?
Yeah.
Well Israel is like,
I mean,
they,
they say like,
if these guys get,
I mean the Israelis did that to the Iraqi,
uh,
um,
to one of the Iraqi facilities back
in the day where they infiltrate in a,
in a,
in a bombed it.
But I guess,
do you ever,
ever listened to George
Galloway speak every,
you know,
who knows?
I think he's like a British name.
He's a pretty champion.
You've got to listen to.
The guy's really,
he's actually very well educated and
he'd make some good arguments and he's,
and it's almost like,
it's funny how he,
like I've seen him get in debates with,
with,
uh,
like,
TV commentators,
like on Sky TV.
He just like destroy annihilates them.
What's his name again?
George Galloway.
There was,
um,
so he was talking about,
I think,
I think it was him that
was talking about like,
somebody came on,
he was talking about this whole,
you know,
possibly doing,
um,
you know,
strategic bombings,
what's it called,
surgical bombings.
And he was like,
t Iran is,
uh,
you know,
some of these cities are densely
populated cities and he's like,
some of these facilities
are in bunkers that are,
you know,
miles down on underneath the ground.
And he's like,
how are you going to do
strategic surgical bombing?
You know,
you have to drop like a nuclear
bomb on the thing to blow it up.
So he's like,
you're out of your mind,
but,
but you should,
but you should check out George Galloway.
He did a thing where it was,
it was around the time when Israel and uh,
and the Lebanese were
fighting like a few years ago.
And this one girl,
it was funny from Sky News,
like they get like this pretty commentator
so she's like here to defend the
Lebanese,
you know the,
the,
his bull us point of view,
George Galloway and the
guy rips into is like,
first of all,
you know,
he's got like,
he's like,
you know,
your,
your introduction of me was
very biased from the Duh,
Duh Duh.
Of course I would expect it to
sky news owned by Rupert Murdoch.
He just goes,
it just cuts into it.
And he's like,
secondly,
you need to know your history.
He's like,
they'd been fighting for did it.
And he just goes into it and
you see this like blonde girl.
Like
could you answer the question
and is he an Irish guy?
I think he's Irish.
I have heard this guy.
The dude is like,
when it comes to arguing,
he's pretty,
he's a pretty bad mother fucker
when it comes to arguing.
Well,
I'll check out some of his stuff on.
I'm,
I'm fascinated by the Middle East,
especially right now because
we're at such a strange time,
you know,
with the Internet and you know,
they're using Facebook to organize and
basically overthrow government after
government and then they keep
toppling one after the other.
And um,
I'm curious as to what
we're actually seeing.
You know,
the problem is,
it's,
it's funny because if you
talk to a lot of Iranians,
we always say like,
for example,
like what happened,
what happened in Egypt?
It's like it was a positive
step in the right direction.
But the question is,
talk to me six months from now,
talking about a year from
now because we'll be,
you know,
well the people that are alive today
even benefit from it or does that make
their life shittier?
And then the next generation
benefits the worlds.
And I'm a fucking turmoil right now.
I don't understand it.
I don't understand economics.
When people start talking
about economic meltdowns,
it's to me,
the way I look at it,
I go,
at the end of the day,
there's the same amount of shit.
And there's the same amount of people.
So what the fuck went wrong?
Yeah,
we were living like kings just to a
couple of years ago and now everybody's
fucking in the shitter because of what?
Because of an inflated
economy and like what?
What does that mean?
I'm part of the things that I'm starting
to see that that makes some sense to me
cause he right.
I I a lot of times get lost in it all too.
But some of the things that started
making sense is when they talked to start
talking about like the difference between
the haves and the have nots and like
how like back in the day,
like a CEO average would
make like 20 times more than,
uh,
than,
than the worker.
Now that some of these CEO's are making
like 350 times more than the average
worker.
So you start going,
okay,
I see.
Like right now they're saying that
a lot of these banks have made them,
like they weren't affected by the,
by,
by the economic crunch
cause we bailed them out.
And now a lot of these bankers
are making a lot more money.
And yet the economy is
supposedly still bad.
And people that had mortgages that were,
you know,
belly up or still belly up
money in and of itself
is so strange to me.
The idea that it's based on nothing
but confidence now there's no,
it's not gold back.
Yeah.
He's just like,
it's so,
it's so hard to pay
attention to everything.
There's just too much shit
going on in the world.
There's too many God damn experiments
going on is too many new science
inventions that I have
to look at every day.
There's some new one they invented where
they installed some micro chip into a
rat's brain and the rat recovered lost
memories and they're thinking they're
gonna eventually be able
to do this to people.
It's just so much fucking shit going on.
I can't pay attention to everything.
It's impossible.
Yeah.
No,
it is.
It's pretty,
it's pretty overwhelming sometimes.
It's a crazy world we live in and we
got a tweet in the middle of all that.
You've got to tweet,
got a tweet.
You had a tweet to what?
How many,
what is your Twitter page?
It's uh,
at Mazda O'Brian.
Master Barney.
Yeah.
I just thought I just kinda got going on.
I've got you here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
so please follow them.
Maz J O B r a n I,
where are you at?
Uh,
soon.
Um,
ah well people can go to the website
or I see what doing this we're doing on
your website.
[inaudible] dot com [inaudible] dot
com and people can go to minivan,
men.com that's you are manager
goal and Chris Spencer.
Yeah,
sounds awesome.
And where can people see you
do stand up comedy store,
Laugh Factory Improv.
Just go to [inaudible]
dot com you can find it
Joe Brian E.
Dot com.
I will be at the Carnegie Music Hall
of a Pittsburgh on this Saturday,
the 25th with Joey Coco Dheas.
And then next Friday,
the 1st of July we're going to
be at the Mandalay Bay theater.
That's a full debt squad show.
Ari,
Ari Shaffir,
Joey Diaz,
me and uh,
Doug Benson is gonna stop by and do a
guest spot and Brian's going to be there
and you can hug him.
There's not going to be a lot of people
in town that weekend cause also there,
Sam's having a 90 show that
weekend for three days straight.
Yeah,
that's really cool.
Strip club and he's
doing it I think Friday,
Saturday and Sunday with Jenna Hayes.
Oh,
okay.
Cool.
Well we'll,
we'll help him promote that as well.
Um,
and yeah,
so we'll,
we'll see you in Vegas
dirty bitches and uh,
so that's it.
Pittsburgh on Saturday the 25th and some
tickets are still available but they're
going quick.
Um,
information is,
uh,
Joe rogan.net.
You could find everything and uh,
we'll be back tomorrow
with Russell Peters and uh,
thank you very much for tuning in and
thank you very much to the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for the fleshlight entering the
code name Rogan,
you will save 15% off the number one sex
toy from and you could shoot some roads
in the benefit
mas,
Joe Brawny,
ladies and gentlemen,
for having me,
man,
pleasure having you on my brother.
It was a very good
catch up with you and see you
again and thank you everybody,
and we'll see you all tomorrow.
Bye Bye.